Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, da sind wir am Start.
Will uns ein paar Schienerstecktausen.
Ich muss erstmal warten, bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream online ist.
In letzter Zeit scheint Twitch hinzukriegen, dass ich fast jedes Mal Quality Options kriege.
Was mich natürlich begeistert, ja.
Und zwar, das ist immer schwierig.
Aber anscheinend hat Twitch hingekriegt.
Übrigens, wo ich auch immer beeindruckt bin, ist über die Wind- und Sound-Settings.
Ja, Mega-Man, halt mal ein bisschen die Klappe.
Wo ich auch immer begeistert bin, ist über die Wind- und Sound-Settings.
Das hört sich jedes Mal, wenn ich mein Headset aufziehe, anders an.
Weiß auch nicht, keine Ahnung, wie die das machen.
Leute, halt euch kurz Achtung, Headset Warning, ich muss mal husten.
So, ich warte jetzt erstmal, bis der Stream richtig am Start ist.
Hallo Zeitwächter YouTube.
Easy as a pocket, Rekt.
Nur Zeitwächter wasser auch, okay.
Ein wildes Poggers.
Kann mir der Twitch mal anzeigen, ob der Stream jetzt richtig live ist?
Ich meine, ich sehe die Vorschau, ich weiß, dass er live ist.
Aber normalerweise steht dann immer unten die Vieweranzahl und die Onlinezeit und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber irgendwie schafft das Twitch gerade noch nicht mehr anzuzeigen.
Und ich warte immer, bis Twitch das schafft.
Dann weiß ich nämlich, dass auch die Notifications raus sind und alles raus ist.
Vieweranzahl steht bei D6, ja.
Dann ist Twitch gerade am Notifications rausschicken und so.
Hat es gerade geklingelt?
Leute, hat es geklingelt?
Okay, ich bin am Start.
Klingelos.
Ich glaube, den Poggers kann man ein bisschen kleiner machen.
So.
So, jetzt dürfte Twitch das kapiert haben, dass der Stream online ist.
Okay, also.
Also, wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen entspannt, dann muss ich wieder an.
Das ist schön entspannt.
Also, was wir heute machen ist, ich muss mir noch mal ganz kurz was aufschreiben.
Ah ja, hier habe ich es, okay.
Also, was wir heute machen, ich zeige euch mal, ich habe ein bisschen China-Kram bestellt,
oder?
Erstmal Linux-VM starten, das brauchen wir nämlich auf jeden Fall heute.
Das ist die falsche VM.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Falsche VM.
Das ist nicht die, ach, da ist die Stream-VM.
Ich bin natürlich auch clever und habe beide VMs exakt gleich benannt.
Das ist natürlich dann ganz, ganz furchtbar, big brain, ja.
Da weißt du auch sofort, was damit gemeint ist, wenn beide VMs gleich heißen.
So, dann nennen wir das jetzt mal, kann man das umbenennen?
Hau auf, auf, naja, wir diskaten das mal, das diskaten wir auch, wo ich gestern ein bisschen
mit TAS Motor rumgespielt habe.
Diskaten wir auch.
Richtig feifett.
Kann man, kann man das?
Ah doch, hier rename.
Priem.
Priem-VM.
So, power on.
Sehr schön.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert das Ganze nämlich auch, weil bei der anderen, in der anderen
VM habe ich in meinem Browser ein Passwörter gespeichert, viel lang geschissen und sonst
was.
Sachen, die ich nicht unbedingt on stream zeigen will, deswegen habe ich eine Stream-VM.
Ich meine, jetzt hat man nichts gesehen, aber glücklicherweise nichts auf, großartig, ja.
So, mal komplizierter Account hier.
Ich erinnere mich so, die Sound-Lautstärke-Settings.
Bisschen, Musik ist bisschen laut, oder?
So, ich glaube, so ist es besser.
Sorry, we have trouble.
Ja, das ist Firefox.
Das war, weiß man nie so genau.
Genau, also, dann zeige ich mal, was wir heute machen.
Ich habe mir nämlich auf Amazon, oder Amazon, wie das die geilen Leute sagen, also nicht
bei AliExpress oder sowas, ich habe mir tatsächlich diesmal bei Amazon Steckdosenleisten bestellt.
Allerdings sind das eindeutig China Steckdosenleisten.
Und zwar der Hersteller heißt, schon super vertrauenserweckend, Kogeek.
Und zwar, jetzt ist ja auch irgendwie lustig, dass es hier die gleiche Steckdosenleiste mit
drei Steckern gibt und die kostet das Doppelte.
Warum kostet die das Doppelte?
Also gekauft habe ich mir die hier für 29 Euro.
Bei AliExpress ist es auch gar nicht so viel billiger.
Hat irgendjemand einen Plassen Schimmer, warum die hier 60 Euro kosten soll und die hier
60 Euro nur die Hälfte, obwohl die, obwohl die mehr USB hat und China-Logik würde ich
mal sagen.
Also da ist echt gebadet für alle, die die 60 Euro Steckdose gekauft haben.
Einfach mal Details, denn ich weiß nicht, ob es dabei Steckdosenleisten so viel krasse
Details gibt, auf die es ankommt.
Im Prinzip ist das ja auch der gleiche Controller drin und die gleiche Software zum Kostenteil.
Naja, wie ich eben auch sage, ich habe die da gekauft.
Und, also wie gesagt, von dem super vertrauenserweckenden Hersteller Kogeek.
Und euch wird auffallen, wenn man, wenn man auf Amazon eine Steckdosenleiste sucht und
dann irgendwie noch dabei Alexa, dann wird euch auffallen, dass es verdammt viele Steckdosenleisten
gibt, die ähm, die genauso aussehen.
Ich mein, hm?
Hm?
Nur, dass das Geekbeast ist und das Kogeek oder, oder das da ist Tonnbuchs oder, oder
Boar, ja, oder Kogeek oder, und es kostet alles was anderes oder Aofo oder, ne, was
haben wir hier noch?
Meros.
Also, es wird uns auffallen, irgendwie ist, ähm, die ist, äh, Fat Rhino 35, das steht
bei allen.
Also das, das ist ja präzise, das ist exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste.
Die anderen schreiben es bloß nicht drauf.
Achso, du meinst die Dreier?
Äh, ja, das kann sein, aber ich geh mal da stark davon aus, dass das alle können, weil
es ist unter der Haube der gleiche Controller und die gleiche App.
Und man sieht es ja auch schon, die gleiche Steckdosenleiste hier kostet hier 38 da irgendwie
mal, ähm, mal 29, meine hat irgendwie 28 oder so gekostet.
Also man sieht schon, im Prinzip ist es exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste, wenn man
sich die hier mit Vieren anguckt, das ist alles exakt das gleiche Design, gleiche Case, gleiche
LED-Positionierung, gleiche Schalter, 4 USB und 4 normale Anschlüsse, Schukkeanschlüsse
für Dinger, für Geräte, ne?
Und die sind ja, der Zeitwächter hat recht, die sind nämlich auch alle vom gleichen Hersteller.
Das kommt alles aus dem gleichen China-Laden und dementsprechend habe ich im Vorfeld geguckt,
welche Steckdosenleiste lässt sich denn gut flashen.
Und so eine richtig gute Anleitung habe ich nicht gefunden, wo drin steht, hey, diese
Anbieter haben wir untersucht und hier, und die funktionieren gut zu flashen.
Allerdings, was, äh, was immer...
Wird die Musik gerade lauter?
Ne, da singt jetzt bloß jemand rum.
Jetzt singt keiner mehr rum.
Ja, was immer ganz interessant ist, sich das anzugucken, ja, ich meine, das ist halt offensichtlich
das Gleiche.
Aber es ist immer ganz interessant zu gucken, auf was basieren die Dinger?
Und wenn man dann, wenn man dann im Internet ein bisschen sucht nach diesen Steckdosenleisten,
kommt man dahinter, dass die Ganze auf einem ESP8266 basieren.
Wer die letzten zwei Streams geguckt hat, der weiß, dass das der kleine Bruder an, äh,
bei, bei Mikrocontrollern ist, zum ESP32, mit dem wir die letzten, die letzten Stunden
rumge, rumgebastelt haben.
So, und Flixscouter, ich bin jetzt seit 10 Minuten online oder so, wir haben auch noch
gar nichts großartig gemacht.
So, und im Prinzip wird wahrscheinlich sowas in der Richtung, sowas kleines, das ist ungefähr
so groß wie euer halber Daumen, so ungefähr.
Daumenspitze bis zum Gelenk vom Daumen, so ungefähr, das ist ein ESP01.
Ja, steht ja auch da.
Sowas ist da wahrscheinlich drin in der Steckdosenleiste.
Und in allen diesen Steckdosenleisten ist das drinne.
Deswegen ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass man das flashen kann.
Und dazu gibt's, und das habt ihr eben auch schon in der anderen VM gesehen, dass ich
schon ein paar Tasmoto Sachen hab, dazu gibt's ein paar ganz gute Customfirmen auf GitHub,
zum Beispiel Tasmoto, Tasmota, Tasmota heißt glaub ich, ne?
Tasmota.
Und das ist ein ziemlich bekanntes Projekt, hat 7000 Sterne auf GitHub, also das ist ziemlich
beliebt.
Was für einen Mehrwert hat das Flaschen, dass die Steckdosenleiste keine China Cloud
verbraucht?
Weil aktuell ist es so, die Steckdosenleiste, dass du sie ordentlich schalten kannst, ich
meine wofür eben eine schaltbare Steckdosenleiste da ist, braucht es zwingend die China Cloud
und zwingend die offizielle App.
Das wäre natürlich stimmt, vielleicht hätte ich mal ein bisschen genauer erklären sollen,
warum man das Ganze überhaupt flashen will.
Wie gesagt, die Steckdosenleiste braucht standardmäßig, braucht die offizielle App und das geht alles
über die China Cloud.
Und ich hab ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock, dass ich meine Steckdosenleiste nur schalten kann,
wenn die China Cloud funktioniert und außerdem will ich überhaupt nicht abhängig sein von
der China Cloud und ehrlich gesagt auch bei mir im WLAN keine Geräte haben, die sich
zur China Cloud verbinden oder irgendwelche Dinge hin übertragen und das vor allem für
eine Steckdosenleiste.
Viele Leute werden wahrscheinlich sich dafür nicht interessieren und werden sagen, ey,
juckt mich nicht, anschließen, easy live, easy China Cloud und das Ganze verwenden.
Allerdings, ich versuch so weit wie es irgendwie geht, was bei einer Heimatautomatisierung
anbelangt, ohne Cloud auszukommen und vor allem ohne China Cloud.
Steckdose mit Cloud, was kommt als nächstes?
Ey, was als nächstes kommt ist, ich zeig's euch, das Klo.
Internet of Shit.
Ne, wie hieß der Typ Twitter hier?
Ne, äh, wie hieß der Typ denn?
Der ist ja doch Internet of Shit.
Der hat nämlich letztens, ne, das ist er auch nicht.
Ach, wie heißt doch, das ist er, glaub ich, oder?
Ja, genau, der hat letztens nämlich einen schönen Link gepostet, ähm, von einem Smart
Klo und ich finde, das Ding sieht übertrieben hässlich aus.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Wassertank im Endeffekt.
Das Einzige, was das hat, ist, dass es billig, billig leucht.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mehr RGB da hinten dran.
Ja, aber was man hier auch schon sieht, obwohl wir wieder beim Thema sind eigentlich ganz
relativ gut, also ich finde die, ich finde die Erklärung vom Hersteller schon mal geil,
ähm, was, was man davon hat, wenn man diesen tollen Klo kauft, ne.
Übrigens, äh, RGB Klo kann man einfacher haben, man kann sich zum Beispiel so einen
Aqua-Klink kaufen, wie ich hab, der hat keine RGBs, allerdings ist er von den Funktionen
her ziemlich gut und auch sehr bequem und sieht nicht so aus, wie irgendwie so ein Typ,
der, der Apple machen will, aber nicht Apple kann, ähm, und der mach ich einfach bei
RGBs, RGB-Scrips dran, wenn ich unbedingt ein RGB-Klo haben will.
Aber die Frage ist natürlich, kann ich wirklich besser kacken, wenn ich ein RGB-Klo hab?
Das sieht wie so ein Plecht-Klo in den, genau, das, genau, das hab ich mir auch gedacht,
ich, ich, ich hab gesagt, das sieht aus wie ein Wassertank, wie so ne, wie so ne, wie so
ne Regentonne, hab ich erst gedacht, wisst ihr, finde ich auch, das sieht aus wie ne Regentonne,
die ihr draußen habt, auch mit dem Deckel und so, das sieht aus wie so ne Regentonne.
Bloß, dass es halt ein Klo ist, der wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich teuer ist, ja, steht, steht
kein, kein Preis dabei, aber ich find, ich find die Erklärung schon wieder geil vom
Hersteller, warum man unbedingt diesen Klo braucht, ähm, dass, dass das, für Beispiel,
im Dunkeln, ja, dann guidet ein der Klo quasi, da führt der Klo ein mit, ähm, dem, dem
Nightlight hilft der dann, dass man den Klo findet, ich weiß nicht, ob irgendjemand von
euch nachts wirklich schon mal Probleme hatte, seinen Klo zu finden.
Soll's vielleicht geben, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hatte nachts noch nie Probleme.
Also mir ist keine, keine Situation bekannt, wo ich nachts am Klo vorbeigelaufen bin und
dann irgendwie auf ein Boot geschossen hab oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, dass ich stell mir das eher vor, so wie ne Landebahn, also Achtung, hierher,
hierher, so, und danach geht's schon weiter, danach geht's schon weiter.
Du musst natürlich die Cola-App verwenden, die natürlich, also, unkreativere Namen kann
man der ganzen Sache ja natürlich nicht geben, wie Cola-Connect.
So, äh, kannst du verschiedene Presets machen und kannst das Ganze auch mit Voice, Kommandos,
dann Existen und sowas, ach ja, und übrigens als Erklärung dafür, was man mit dem Klo
macht, wenn man halt mal nicht drauf, drauf sitzt, ist, ähm, dass man tolle Lightning-
und Sound-Features vor dem Klo verwenden kann.
Und im Zweifelsfall kann ich Alexa im Klo fragen, also, was auch immer, also, das ist der nächste
Schritt.
Und ich glaube, wer das gesehen hat hier, der wird sich nicht drüber wundern, dass es
Steckdosen leisten gibt, die ne Cloud brauchen.
Oder wundert sich da jetzt noch irgendjemand?
Easy.
Ok, ähm, erst mal zurück zum eigentlichen Thema, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Leute?
Ähm, genau, sowas ist da drinnen in der Steckdosenleiste.
Twitch über Xbox, der Sebaro, wer macht dann auch sowas?
Du als ausgebildeter, fertig gelernter Fachinformatiker jetzt, der müsste das eigentlich schon besser
können, Twitch über die Xbox.
Ich hab übrigens PS5-Leaks vorhin gesehen, ähm, dass angeblich Bad Company 3 auf der
PS5-Initial rauskommt.
Aber ich hoffe, die machen nicht so'n Scheiß wie bei Bad Company 1, dass es nicht für
den PC kommt.
Nun gut, ähm, das ist in der Steckdosenleiste drin.
Also, und wir haben gesehen, im Prinzip ist es egal, ob wir jetzt die Geekbi, Geek, Geek,
ist gar nicht Geekbi, ich hab mich verlesen, Geekbess?
Ist den Chinesen auch kein Name mehr eingefallen, oder?
Geekbess, wollen die Geekbest vielleicht schreiben?
Auf der anderen Seite, Kogeek ergibt auch nicht viel Sinn, ne?
Ja, und zu Ende sowas ist da drin.
Und, ähm, ich hab das hier schonmal geflasht, also ich kenn mich da so'n bisschen damit
aus, allerdings flasht man das, so wie ich das gelesen hab, auf diese Steckdosenleisten
nicht direkt.
Und das ist ein ziemlich bekanntes Projekt, wie gesagt 7000 Sterne auf GitHub, und funktioniert
für saumäßig viele Geräte aus China, ähm, wie gesagt Steckdosenleisten, Steckdosen,
alles im Prinzip, wo ein ESP8266 drin steckt, und lässt sich auch relativ einfach flaschen,
wenn, und jetzt kommt der große Knackpunkt, ähm, wenn man Zugang zu den Pins hat.
Und, es heißt, entweder muss ich das Ding aufschrauben und gucken, ob ich irgendwie
an die Pins drankomm, oder ich verwende was anderes.
Und zwar, da hab ich, sonst würd ich den Stream jetzt gar nicht machen im Endeffekt,
weil ich hab natürlich im Vorfeld schonmal geguckt, was es da gibt, und zwar um relativ
einfach das Motor auf so'ne Steckdosenleiste drauf zu kriegen.
So sieht das Ganze dann aus, ihr habt's eben schon gesehen in der anderen VM, also so'n
Webinterface kriegt man dann im Endeffekt auf die Steckdosenleiste, und man kann das
danach quasi so als vollwertige IP-Steckdosenleiste verwenden.
Und wenn ihr euch mal anguckt, was richtige IP-Steckdosenleisten kosten, jetzt sind wir
auch dabei, was es letztendlich bringt, ähm, was richtige IP-Steckdosenleisten kosten,
da werdet ihr sehen, klar, die sind bestimmt auch ein bisschen professioneller, wie Kougeek
oder Kougbess, äh, aus China, aber für den Heimgebrauch reichen die, und sind deutlich
günstiger als IP-Steckdosenleisten für 250 Euro aufwärts.
Ah, genau, sowieso wird das dann am Ende aussehen, da haben wir dann hier ein paar
Schalter, und können die Steckdosenleiste remote einen ausschalten, und natürlich können
wir das Ganze auch, ja, so sieht das dann aus, genau, kann man dann hier wahrscheinlich
einen ausschalten, ja.
Genau, und, ähm, das Schöne daran ist, dass man das natürlich auch wunderbar, das ist
eine Open-Source-Firmware für eben alle ESP-8266-Controller, dass man das wunderbar
auch in seine Heimautomatisierung integrieren kann, also sprich, das Ding hat entweder schon
vorgefertigte Settings dabei für unterschiedliche Heimautomatisierungslösungen, oder im Prinzip
alles, was man braucht, also es ist total, total einfach, und im Prinzip kann man auch
nie genug Steckdosenleisten haben, haben die Steckdosenleisten Überspannungsschutz,
angeblich schon, aber ich wäre da generell vorsichtig, was die Chinesen auf die Produkte
draufschreiben, die haben hinten drauf ja auch alle möglichen Prüf-Siegel, ähm, die
in Europa erforderlich sind, da ist alles hinten drauf, ja, Tripolon sind sie, zumindest
ist das Logo drauf, ob die wirklich geprüft sind, da kann man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
drüber streiten, aber, aber die China Electric Sachen sind, wenn man, wenn man, ähm, also
die, die, die, diese Mainstream Sachen, die sind gar nicht so extrem scheiße wie ihren
Ruf, zum Beispiel diese ganzen Sonoff-Dinger, ähm, die berichten, dass den Leuten, die
das Haus abbrennt, davon hält sich doch entglänzen.
Genau, die Prüf-Siegel kannste vollknicken.
Max hat bald ein Smart-Home, ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich bald eins habe, ich habe eigentlich
schon ein, äh, ziemlich smartes Home, ja, es fehlen noch ein paar Sachen, aber das sagt
man immer, weil eigentlich, doch das muss, muss euch bewusst sein, wenn ihr irgendwie
mal anfängt mit dieser Smart-Home-Geschichte, ihr werdet nie fertig.
Ihr werdet, ihr werdet nie fertig.
Immer wenn ihr was macht, fallen euch während ihr es macht, fünf weitere Sachen, an die
ihr noch machen könnt.
Und das hört nie auf.
Wie gesagt, ich bin auch nicht von Anfang an auf die Idee von, äh, von IoT Graveyard
gekommen, ja, das wird das verstehen, als wenn die Leute die letzten zwei Streams geguckt
haben, aber letztendlich ist es praktisch, ja.
Ein Smart-Home am besten noch mit dem Tasker auf dem Handy verbinden, hab ich ja.
Ich hab im Flur hab ich zwei oben und unten, neben der Gegensprechanlage von der Tür
hab ich zwei Fire HD10 hängen, das sind die, so die billig Amazon-Pads, die aktuell 250
kosten, aber die würd ich mir nicht kaufen für 150, sondern ich würd warten, bis es
an Weihnachten, die wieder für, ich glaub, 60 Euro oder sowas gegeben hat, das letzte
Mal, und dann würd ich zuschlagen.
Ich hab mir letztes Jahr vor Weihnachten extra zwei, ähm, lohnt es sich deine LoRa-Stream
nachzugucken, kannst du kurz zusammenfassen, was du gemacht hast?
Nicht viel, ich hab, ähm, das LoRa-Modul angestöpselt an den ESP32 NodeMCU und ich
hab, ähm, paar LoRa-Messages geschickt über, über eine Arduino LoRa Library.
Nicht viel, also nicht viel mehr, als das Example auf GitHub hergibt.
Genau, und, ähm, die Dinger kann man mittlerweile, wie das der Tribolon auch sagt, mittlerweile
kann man die Amazon, alle, alle, äh, Fire-Tablets, äh, flashen, außer, außer, sorry, das stimmt
nicht ganz, außer das Fire 7 2019.
Das kann man, soweit ich das gelesen hab, aktuell nicht routen und, ähm, kriegt da
auch nichts gescheit drauf.
Wobei man, ich glaub ich, aber einen Custom-Launcher auch auf die normalen, ungerouteten Fire
hinkriegt.
Kein eigenes LoRa-Gateway, ne, hab ich noch nicht gebaut, ich hab aktuell LoRa P2P gemacht,
was jetzt für zwei Geräte auch reicht, aber ich will mir ein eigenes LoRa-Gateway ans Dach
bauen.
Zumal es bei uns noch kein, ähm, kein Skip in der Nähe.
Ja.
So, und so zwei Tablets hab ich eben flur an der Wand, unter anderem mit Tasker drauf,
ähm, weil Tasker einfach so eines der besten Android-Apps ist.
Und was auch noch gut ist, ist Thermux heißt das?
Das ist quasi ein Linux für, ein Linux für Android.
Das ist auch praktisch, wenn man kleine Sachen drauf laufen lassen will, die lassen sich
manchmal in fünf Zeilen, äh, Code auf der Shell einfacher lösen als in 30 einträglichen
Tasker.
Aber an sich ist Tasker Pflicht auf diesen Dingern.
Ja.
Äh, so eine Wall-Mount-Commando-Zentrale ist bestimmt geil.
Ja, das riecht praktisch.
Ähm, zum Beispiel haste halt die, die, die Homes, ich kanns euch jetzt nicht zeigen,
ich hab da ein bisschen zu viel persönliche Sachen drin, ich guck mal, ob ich das vielleicht
mal irgendwie, irgendwie hinkrieg.
Ähm, haste dann im Wand, haste, hab ich eingestellt das Tablet, dass wenn du vorbeiläufst, das
automatische Bildschirm angeht, kannst du einstellen.
Mit der, mit der passenden, mit den passenden Apps kannst du das einstellen.
Einfach, wenn die Kamera eine gewisse Bewegung erkennt, geht das Tablet automatisch an.
Und dann geht das an und dann geht halt direkt, ist dann Unlocked und dahinter ist dann halt
die, die Home Assistant Startseite und da haste dann alle möglichen Optionen.
Kannste, kannst du nach Türstatus gucken, Fensterstatus, äh, Rollläden, Stromverbrauch,
äh, kannst Sachen ein- und ausschalten.
Dies zum Beispiel auch die Bahnverspätung hat, alle, alle, alle möglichen, alle möglichen
Dingern.
Staubsauger, die Staubsauger-Roboter kannst du anschmeißen.
Also im Prinzip alles, was irgendwie in der Heimautomatisierung drinne ist, kannst du
über diese, über die Tablets im Flur auch steuern.
So.
Achso, dann zeigt es auch noch an, wie viel Temperatur im Teich im Garten ist, dass man
sieht, dass es demnächst zufriert, dass man vielleicht im Winter mal gucken muss.
Dann hab ich noch drinne die, äh, die Lieferdienste von Amazon, die oftmals kommen, also sprich
DPD, DHL, UPS und Amazon Logistik selbst.
Da hab ich ein bisschen was gebastelt, was das Ganze funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, Stromverbrauch sieht man auch.
So, alles mit History.
Äh, ob die Heizung im Keller Fehler hat.
Also, bla, ja.
Wohnst du noch in dem Haus von deinem Opa, ja?
Ja.
Mach ich.
Ähm, und, meine neueste Spielerei ist halt, äh, Boden, Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren für
die Blumen auf der Terrasse und im Hof.
Garten ist egal, Garten kann zuwachsen.
Aber in einer normalen 2-4 Zimmerwohnung braucht man sowas kaum.
Selbst da kann man nützliche Sachen machen.
Man sollte eh bei der ganzen Heimautomatisierung nicht mit dem anfangen, was man in irgendwelchen
Foren sieht, sondern, also es sei denn, es ist was dabei, was einem gefällt, sondern
man sollte mit dem anfangen, von dem man es am nützlichsten für einen selbst hält.
Weil sonst hast du dann irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungsdinger gemacht, einfach weil es geht und ohne,
dass es dir was bringt.
Also eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gemacht hab, ist beispielsweise die RGB-Lampe, die
mir anzeigt, ob die Bahnverspätung hat morgens.
Ich hab, äh, Schlafzimmer ist neben am Arbeitszimmer, wenn ich raus in den Flur komm.
Und ich hab an der Arbeitszimmertür als Außen eine Lampenfassung dran.
Die war mal ursprünglich gedacht dafür, dass wenn ich irgendwelche YouTube-Videos aufnehme,
dass hat keiner auf die Idee, um die Tür aufzumachen.
Ähm, und da hab ich jetzt eine RGB-Lampe reingestöpselt und die hat morgens ab 5 Uhr
30 geht die glaube ich an, ähm, also ich seh mal an, wenn ich aufstehe, hat die quasi
je nachdem, wie viel Verspätung die Bahn hat, wenn man das schon weiß, hat die eine unterschiedliche
Farbe.
Von grün bis rot.
Über gelb.
Und orange.
Das, äh, das war eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gemacht hab, weil ich das halt sehr
praktisch fand.
Und dann, und ab da ging's dann, ging's dann weiter, ja.
Und was ich auch denke, was richtig was bringt, ist, dass mir, dass ich jetzt eine Warnung
gebaut hab, wenn der Teich im Garten zufriert, weil den muss man abdecken, sonst geht's
kaputt.
Auch ein bisschen blöd.
Und die Steuerung von die, also die Kameras sind natürlich auch drin und die Steuerung
für die Staubsaugerroboter auch.
Das ist alles relativ praktisch und ich kann so einen Staubsaugerroboter auch nur empfehlen,
sich sowas zu holen.
Ich dachte am Anfang auch, so ein Scheiß braucht keiner.
Aber das ist doch wirklich nicht schlecht, das Ding.
Das, poch, wie geht das jetzt, uff.
Das ist wirklich ganz nice.
Gut, jetzt haben wir aber ganz schön lange geschwätzt.
Wie gesagt, so ein Ding hab ich hier an der Wand hängen, oben und unten, neben der Türgegensprechanlage.
Die Türgegensprechanlage ist noch nicht richtig integriert, da bin ich doch am Basteln.
Und man kann einfach so schnell zugreifen, weil sonst muss man immer gucken, ah Scheiße,
wo hab ich mein Tablet hingelegt.
Wobei im Prinzip fast mittlerweile in jeder Ecke irgendwo hier ein Tablet rumfliegt.
Aber damit ist es ganz praktisch.
Und es ist, ich hatte richtig Glück, dieses Tablet passt genau in den Spal zwischen Türgegensprechanlage
und der Wand.
Das muss ich auch nicht mal festmachen.
Das war so, so, ja, hat sich so glücklich ergeben.
Aussebarer, frei bis Oktober, das ist, das ist sehr nice.
Krass, wie fortschrittlich Max ist.
Man muss sich einfach überlegen, was für ein Selbstvers bringt.
Und ja, nachdem ich ja quasi mein Geld mit Technik, Linux und Computerkrams verdiene irgendwo,
im weiteren Sinne und es halt auch ein Gebiet ist, was mir Spaß macht.
Allerdings ich auf der Arbeit zu programmieren eher weniger komme, als mir lieb ist,
ist natürlich sowas für mich daheim in der Supergeschichte.
Ja und außerdem bringt es für alle irgendwo was.
Ja, so, aber jetzt fangen wir erstmal an, weil ich laber schon wieder,
warte mal, wie lange bin ich jetzt immer?
Uptime, zeig mal her, warte mal her.
Uptime, wie lange bin ich jetzt schon online und hab noch nichts gemacht?
30 Minuten, okay, 30 Minuten geschwätzt ist jetzt genug.
Also unser Ziel ist auf die Steckdosenleiste von Kogeek.
Ich finde immer noch der Name, klingt super vertrauenserweckend.
MonkaSmoak, das Emote gab es nicht.
Hätte es das Emote gegeben, würde ich MonkaSmoak für jeden China Stream freischalten.
Wüsste, als MonkaSmoak müsste man echt einer machen als Emote.
Genau und unser Ziel ist, dass wir auf die Steckdosenleiste Tasmota kriegen,
dass wir das ganze schön schalten können, wie man es halt mit so einer IP Steckdosenleiste macht.
Und ich hab ein schönes Projekt gefunden, das nennt sich, äh, ne nicht Tasmota, Tuya, Tuya Convert.
Das ist ursprünglich von irgendeinem Redakteur von der CT, glaube ich.
Aber, und wenn das damit funktioniert, ist das wirklich, ähm, easy.
Also wirklich sehr easy, wenn das damit funktioniert.
Das ist, äh, das ist quasi, steht doch irgendwie, eine Scriptsammlung für einen Raspberry Pi.
Das macht man da einfach drauf, führt ein paar Kommandos aus und dann macht es den WLAN Access Point auf.
Man versetzt, ich hab mir das schon ein bisschen durchgelesen, dann versetzt man seine Steckdosenleiste
in den Pairing Modus und dann macht er das.
Kommt noch was auf YouTube? Ähm, ja.
Ich kann ja auch noch nicht sagen genau wann.
So, das heißt das erste was wir jetzt machen müssen, und das geht schnell,
ich hab mir nämlich zwei neue, ähm, Raspberry Pi Packs bestellt,
weil ich eh noch zwei neu, weil ich eh noch zwei gebraucht hab.
Also, zwei ist, eigentlich, eigentlich brauch ich einen, aber warum soll ich nur einen bestellen?
Ähm, und den einen Pack machen wir mal auf, der ist fix und fertig mit, ähm, Netzteil, SD-Karte und Gehäuse.
Und als erstes schnappen wir uns mal die SD, ups, schnappen wir uns mal die SD-Karte und flashen da ein aktuelles, äh, Respian Stretch drauf.
Und dann machen wir ihn an. Und dann machen wir China Cloud-Gedöns drauf.
So, also müssen wir uns erstmal einen Respian runterladen.
Kannst du sagen was auf YouTube kommt?
Das ist nicht die normale Respian-Seite.
Ach, Raspberry Pi Org war's. Und das ist Respian Org.
Ok, da gibt's Unterschiede. Ach, tatsächlich ist die richtige Seite. Ich geh mal über die.
Ähm, kannst du sagen was auf YouTube kommt? Naja, ich hab mir in den letzten Monaten und Jahren quasi schon so viele Themen aufgeschrieben.
Ähm, ich kann mal reingucken.
Aber im Prinzip heißt es nicht, dass davon, dass davon was kommt.
Ich muss mich einfach mal wieder so in der Stimmung fühlen, YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Wärmung auf YouTube und Twitch in letzter Zeit übelst überhand nimmt.
Und ein Thema, was mir persönlich sehr am Herzen liegt, ist, das wollte ich schon lange in meinen YouTube-Videos ansprechen.
Allerdings ist es so ein Thema, wo ich sag, wo ich mir halt so denke, ja, das ist wieder sowas, da springen die Leute drauf an.
Und zwar, dass in letzter Zeit so krass die Leute durch jeden Scheiß getriggert sind. Das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Ich war letztens, als wir gegrillt haben, war ich bei Chefkoch.
Das ist so eine Seite, wo es Forum mit Rezepten und so gibt.
Und da hab ich nach, was war das denn?
Ich hab nach irgendeinem Rezept gesucht und bin dann in das Chefkoch-Forum gekommen.
Und da hat irgendeiner dann im Forum geschrieben, ja, dieses Rezept ist quasi nach alter Indianer-Tradition.
Und da haben die Leute nicht etwa über das Rezept gesprochen, sondern, dass er das Wort Indianer verwendet hat.
Und nicht irgendwie nordamerikanische Ureinwohner oder sowas.
Dann hab ich mir gedacht, Leute, ihr seid wirklich mittlerweile über wirklich jeden Scheiß getriggert, über alles.
Da wollte ich mich auch mal, da wollte ich mich echt mal drüber auslassen.
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Tracer-Vorfall, äh, nicht an den Tracer-Vorfall, ähm, an...
Ja doch, an den Tracer-Vorfall in Overwatch erinnern.
Da waren die Leute auch wieder krass getriggert.
Ich mein, nicht den Hintern von Tracer.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht der Hintern, nicht der Hintern.
So, ich lad mal kurz, äh, während ich laber, das lädt ja kurz ne Minute.
Mal, äh, das aktuelle Demian runter.
Dass die lesbisch, nein, auch nicht, dass die lesbisch ist.
Ähm, es gab doch mal diesen...
Wie war das noch mal?
Genau, es gab doch in Overwatch diesen, doch, doch, genau, doch.
Der Beatbro hat, ne, äh, wer hat's gesagt, äh, Choose My Name hatte recht, genau.
Es gab doch ein Comic, ein Overwatch-Comic, ähm, wo Tracer ne Freundin hatte.
Und was ich lustig fand, damals, weil die ganzen krassen Feministen und sonst was,
waren übelst getriggert, dass Tracer quasi lesbisch ist im Comic.
Weißt du, vorher, überall irgendwie erzählt so nach dem,
oder man fühlt sich nicht richtig respektiert und repräsentiert und sonst was.
Und dann kommt Blizzard und macht quasi einen der Aushängeschilder.
In einem offiziellen Comic, äh, sagen sie das.
Und wisst ihr, was die Antwort war?
Wisst ihr, was die Antwort war?
Nicht etwa irgendwie, wir haben da dran was auszusetzen.
Da haben wir gesagt, nein.
Also, was uns stört, ist, dass Tracer ein Charakter ist,
der explizit für das männliche Auge designed wurde.
Und das geht nicht.
Jetzt überlegt euch doch mal im Umkehrschluss.
Sie hätten Saria genommen oder sowas.
Dann hätten sie gesagt, ah, Alter, so ein Klischee hier wieder.
Kackspasten bei Blizzard, ey, das geht nicht.
Aber die Erklärung ist schon wieder so, äh, nicht, nicht, äh,
nicht in meinem Brain irgendwie zu verarbeiten.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, äh, nicht, dass ein Charakter,
der extra für das männliche Auge designed ist.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Bam.
Es gibt echt Leute, die haben hobbymäßig nichts anderes zu tun,
wie sich aufzuregen.
Und außerdem, was auch die Leute mal irgendwie langsam lernen sollten,
was, wo wir viele, viele Schwierigkeiten haben, ist, ähm,
mal zu erkennen, dass die Welt, äh, nicht nur schwarz und weiß ist.
Na, also du kannst beispielsweise, was, was sehen wir mal,
du kannst für Umweltschutz sein, aber gegen Elektroautos zum Beispiel.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding, kannst du machen, ja.
Du kannst, du kannst unsere Einwanderungspolitik in Frage stellen,
aber, ähm, trotzdem sagen, man will nicht, dass Leute ertrinken.
Man kann irgendwie sagen, äh, was weiß ich, ähm,
mir fällt jetzt nichts ein.
Ihr wisst ja aber, was ich meine, dass, dass Sachen halt durchaus
eine Person gegensätzliche Ansichten haben kann in unterschiedlichen Themen.
Ja, man kann auch sagen, ja, äh, ich mag Tradition und gehe auf Drachtenfeste,
aber ich will auch, dass Schwule heiraten dürfen.
Das ist, die Welt ist halt nicht schwarz und weiß.
Naja, ist auch scheißegal jetzt, wir machen jetzt,
wir machen jetzt Respion auf unsere Raspberry Pi drauf.
Ähm, so, zack, Siste, Download, Completed.
Das hat nur drauf gewartet, dass ich aufhör zu schwätzen.
Downloads, zack, respion.
So, bestes, bestes, ähm, bestes Flashtool.
Äh, eigentlich bescheuertes Flashtool,
weil warum muss ich, um ein Image zu flashen,
unter Linux eine Elektron-Anwendung starten?
Aber wir sind im Jahr 2019, da ist das so.
Äh, Etcher zum Flaschen.
Oh, ich sollte vielleicht vorher mal die SD-Karte einlegen.
Wo habe ich die SD-Karte und wo ist mein Reader?
Mein SD-Karten-Reader.
Ah, hier, so, SD-Karten-Reader.
SD-Karte rein, gleich mal blub blub blub blub blub.
Wenn ich die SD-Karte...
Habt ihr das Problem bei Mikro-SD-Karten auch immer,
dass ihr die immer fünfmal, ähnlich wie bei USB-Anschlüssen,
immer fünfmal in unterschiedliche Richtungen reinschieben müsst,
bis es funktioniert?
Bist du manchmal froh, dich von YouTube weitgehend verabschiedet zu haben?
Naja, also ich kann mich halt null internifizieren mit dem,
was in YouTube Deutschland gemacht wird.
Ich kann gar nicht sagen, dass ich das hasse oder so.
Mir ist es einfach vollkommen egal.
Ich kriege dann manchmal Videos empfohlen.
Und dann hast du dann irgendwie...
Wen hast du denn da? Zum Beispiel so ApoRed.
So, wie macht der immer?
Digga! Digga!
Das ist einfach nicht meine Zielgruppe.
Ich bin einfach nicht die Zielgruppe davor.
Genau, genau.
Nein, Digga! Digga!
Naja, also wirklich verabschiedet habe ich mich ja nicht.
Wenn ich mich verabschiedet hätte, hätte ich ein Abschiedsvideo gemacht.
Wir connecten das mal zu unserer VM.
Die SD-Karte.
Nein, ich will nicht meine 30 Milliarden Devices connecten zur VM.
Hoffentlich habe ich jetzt mein Mikrofon nicht zur VM connectet.
Sondern nur...
Nur die SD-Karte will ich connecten.
Ah, der Tribulon folgt mir auf Twitter, so wie es aussieht.
Heute hatte ich am Südbahnhof auch wieder einen, ey.
Ich hasse alle Deutsche, außer Fußballer.
Was meint ihr, was los wäre, wenn ich abends vorbeilaufen würde?
Und würde sagen, ich hasse alle Türken.
Da hast du gleich 10 Stück vor dir stehen.
Was, Alter?
Der Typ heute.
Du musst ja heute echt aufpassen, was du sagst.
Mittlerweile wird dir alles und jedes irgendwie als...
Oder Max ist bestimmt rechtsgesinnt oder so.
Alles, ja.
Aber dem kann ich nur sagen, guckt euch mal meine Videos auf YouTube zu diesem Thema an.
Ich habe ja ein paar Videos zu Themen in dieser Richtung gemacht.
Ich glaube, da ist das ein bisschen besser als hier im Stream.
So.
Übrigens, was ich gut finde...
Wenn ich eh schon zu dem Thema was gesagt habe, was ich ganz gut finde, ist,
dass sehr viele junge Leute jetzt mittlerweile aufgewacht sind, sich da dran...
Was geht mit der Musik eigentlich gerade ab?
Wartet mal kurz.
Die Musik geht mir gerade voll auf den Sack.
Was ich gut finde, dass viele junge Leute quasi sie jetzt dafür interessieren und aufgewacht sind.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin alles andere als irgendwie sonderlich politisch aktiv.
Ich will mit der ganzen Sache eigentlich nichts zu tun haben.
Eigentlich bin ich da recht egoistisch eingestellt.
Ich will eigentlich nur mal ein Zeug machen und sonst soll ich meine Ruhe haben.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass sich viele junge Leute jetzt für die ganze Sache interessieren.
Weil, und das habe ich auch damals gesagt, wo abgestimmt wurde...
Ich flash mal die SD-Karte der Zwischenzeit, wo ich laber.
Dort gibt es ja nichts, wo ich zu erzählen muss.
Downloads.
16 GB Flash.
Zum Thema, wo es ums Urheberrecht ging, dass die wirklich einen Fehler gemacht haben.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt nur in der EU, auch in Deutschland.
Die haben wirklich einen Fehler gemacht.
Die haben ganz viele junge Leute aufgeweckt, sich dafür zu interessieren.
Die vorher eigentlich immer im Hinterkopf hatten.
Ah ja, muss mich nicht jucken.
Das machen die schon.
Und irgendwie werden sie schon in meinem Interesse machen.
Und da ist ganz vielen Leuten auf einen Schlag klar geworden.
So, ey, fuck, da passiert ja überhaupt nichts in meinem Interesse.
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, der Axel Forst zum Beispiel.
Was der für einen Stuss von sich gegeben hat, er.
Oder wo der, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war, irgendeinen CSU-Dude,
dem dener erstmal in der Talkshow erklären muss, dass er schon jetzt,
wer hätte das gedacht, urheberrechtlich geschützte Sachen auf YouTube nicht hochladen kann.
Das war für dener was ganz Neues.
Dem musste er dann erstmal erzählen, hier, Kollege, also,
wenn ich jetzt ein YouTube-Video mache und da läuft im Radio der falsche Song,
dann bin ich jetzt schon gefickt, ohne euren Scheiß.
Das hat er so nicht gesagt, aber sinngemäß war das so gemeint.
Und da hat dann der CDU-Typ erstmal so geguckt, sagt er.
Ach, wirklich, ist das so?
Ah, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Und zumindest haben sich ganz viele Leute jetzt damit aufgeweckt,
dass die sich auf einmal dafür interessieren.
Anders ist das auch nicht zu erklären.
Und ich glaube, dass, und das habe ich auch gesagt, wo diese Abstimmung war,
ich glaube, dass diese Abstimmung über diese Urheberrechtsgeschichte genau nach hinten losgeht,
dass das genau zur richtigen Zeit falsch gelaufen ist,
dass es tatsächlich mal was bewirken könnte.
Jetzt nicht urheberrechtsgeschichtsmäßig,
sondern diese ganze Geschichte, die jetzt zusammenkommt.
Erst, dass die Leute sich dadurch aufgeweckt wurden
durch die Abstimmung über diese Urheberrechtsgeschichte,
dann das Zerstörer-Video, da kam er noch dabei,
und die haben ja zwischenzeitlich auch selbst ganz viele merkwürdige Dinge gemacht.
Dass jetzt diese ganze Umweltdemo-Geschichten am Start sind,
das kommt alles, finde ich, relativ glücklich zusammen gerade.
Und ich meine, es betrifft ja vor allem auch die jungen Leute.
Und deswegen finde ich es gerade gut, dass da so viele dabei sind.
So.
Gut, wir haben eine SD-Karte gebrannt.
Äh, gebrannt?
Alter.
Also wir haben jetzt krass SD-Karte hier gekopier...
Copyright, äh, striked, was auch immer.
So, SD-Karte, nee, Moment, ich muss noch was machen.
Ähm, also wir haben die SD-Karte geflasht.
Graviert ge-edged haben wir sie.
Ja, richtig, wir haben sie.
Und, äh, jetzt müssen wir die SD-Karte nochmal kurz mounten.
Erstmal gucken, welches Device das ist.
SD-B, okay.
Wenn man sich nicht sicher ist, guckt man einfach F-Disc minus SD-B.
Und stellt fest, okay, das ist SD-Transel, blablabla, 16G.
So, und dann mounten wir die SD-Karte mal.
Nämlich mit Boot bei uns hier unter Mount, gehen da rein.
Und weil es ein Raspberry ist, machen wir einmal Touch SSH.
Das sorgt dafür, das ist so eine Sache, die muss man nur bei einem Raspberry machen.
Die sorgt dafür, dass man sich nachdem der Raspberry gebootet ist, per SSH einloggen kann.
So.
Quatsch.
Okay, jetzt haben wir die SD-Karte fertig.
Jetzt kann ich den SD-Karten wieder rausziehen und die Karte in meinen Raspberry einführen.
Äh, wo ist er? Hier.
Und nicht, warum die die Position zwischen dem 2er und 3er geändert haben von der SD-Karte.
Äh, ich guck mal kurz in den Chat.
Ich hab gesehen, da wurde richtig viel geschrieben und ich hab jetzt gar nicht reingeguckt letzter Zeit.
Ähm...
Was für eine Linux-Distribution benutzt du gerade?
Ich muss erstmal gucken, wo ich aufgehört hab Chat zu gucken.
Das ist Banjaro. Banjaro Linux.
Äh, und was ich richtig cool find, ich benutze das ja schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Damals war das noch relativ neu und auch noch nicht so beliebt.
Aber mittlerweile, das ist übrigens ne Seite, kommt dir vor wie 1990.
Mittlerweile ist Banjaro eines, was eigentlich MX Linux war, das hab ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Probier ich auch nicht aus.
Grafische Oberflächen in der Form ist eh nicht mein Fall.
Äh, mittlerweile ist Banjaro ganz oben in der Beliebtheitsskala.
Also manchmal setzt sich doch gute Sachen durch.
Banjaro ist wirklich, wirklich, finde ich, ne gute Distribution.
Es ist ne Art Linux mit nem ordentlichen Installer.
Das ist alles, was ich schon immer machen wollte.
Und, ach so, die Oberfläche ist, wie gesagt, das ist Banjaro Linux mit i3-WM als Oberfläche.
Und ein bisschen Anpassungen, aber ansonsten hältst du dir den Grenzen.
Es gibt sogar im Archiv nen Stream, wo wir das eingerichtet haben zusammen.
Äh, nice, Ebaro hat ne 100K-Leitung von der Telekom.
Ja, aber mir gibt's demnächst Unity Media 400 down, 20 ab.
Und Telekom, äh, wird gekündigt.
Was ich mal vor Jahren über Mobilfunkt-Tarif in Deutschland aufgeregt,
denkst du, das hat sich mittlerweile verbessert?
Ähm, ein bisschen ja.
Ja, ein bisschen besser ist es geworden.
Ich hab jetzt gelesen, dass die Telekom nen Tarif hat für, wo YouTube-Nutzung quasi include ist.
Also Snapchat, YouTube, Twitch und so Zeug ist da, glaub ich, drinne für 5€ im Monat.
Ähm, also es bewegt sich in die richtige Richtung.
Äh, ja und Tribulon, das hab ich auch gelesen.
Jetzt haben sie offiziell gesagt, dass die Breitbandziele 2018 nicht erreicht wurden.
Allerdings, wenn mir auf Twitter folgt, ich hab diesen Tweet vom Regierungssprecher, glaube ich, im Laufe des Jahres 2018, 5x oder so,
immer mal wieder retweetet, so mit neuem Kommentar dabei, so, äh, das sieht aber knapp aus, sieht aber knapp aus.
Also es ist schon Ende 2018, sieht aber knapp aus, hat sich keiner für interessiert.
Und die Telekom konnte mir bis zum Schluss nicht sagen, ob diese Geschichte,
weil die Telekom war der Einzige, die darauf geantwortet haben, ich mein, man muss ja nicht irgendwie, äh, denken, der Regierungssprecher würde darauf antworten oder so.
Ähm, die Telekom hat aber am Anfang darauf geantwortet, so nach dem Motto, dass sie da, äh, super am Ausbauen sind und die geilsten sind.
Dann hatte ich die Telekom gefragt, so sag mal, ähm, ist da eigentlich auch schon, sind da Mobiltechnologien dabei oder meint ihr wirklich Festnetz?
Ich meine, die sprechen zwar immer von Festnetz, also von Versorgung und so, meinen die, meinen die wirklich, was meinen die?
Konnten sie mir nicht sagen, aber ich bin mir nahezu sicher, da ist natürlich LTE und ganze Geschiss dabei.
Sonst ist es in Deutschland gar nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich für unsere Anbieter.
So, der Raspberry hat die SD-Karte drin. Ich werde den mal anschließen und dann, äh, probieren wir das hier mal aus, unsere Steckdosenleiste zu flashen.
Ich muss mal die Klima nach anmachen, die ist gerade übertrieben warm drinne. Na gut, ich hab zwei Rechte an.
Zwei Rechte an, Tür zu. Aber wird schon, schon ein bisschen warm.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal den Raspberry anschließen an ein USB-Kabel.
Ups. Schließen wir den jetzt am besten an, hier auf der linken Seite, auf der rechten Seite.
Mal gucken, dass ich nicht übers Kabel fahre gleich. So, Raspberry.
Ich schließe den auf der linken Seite an, weil da liegt ein Netzwerkkabel und ich gehe davon aus,
dass ich die Netzwerkkarte, also die Wifi-Netzwerkkarte auf dem Raspberry brauche für die Steckdosenleiste zum Flashen.
Und deswegen muss ich ein Kabel einstöpseln fürs Netzwerk.
Deswegen legen wir den Raspberry einfach mal hier neben auf den Rechner drauf.
So, USB. Anschließen.
So, Raspberry booted. Schauen wir mal.
Ja.
Stream on mit Social-Gedöns. Ja, genau das meine ich.
Was ich auch gelesen habe, ist, dass die Telekom oder Bandit generell für den Netzebausbau
theoretisch 4,5 Milliarden zur Verfügung standen und sie es irgendwie geschafft haben,
davon irgendwie nur 450 Millionen oder sogar 140 Millionen oder so auszugeben.
Ich meine, wenn du 4,5 Milliarden hast und es nur schaffst überhaupt,
140 Millionen auszugeben und dann machst du irgendwas verkehrt,
das hin- und herschieben kostet ja schon mehr.
Aber sonderliche Kompetenz traue ich auf diesem Gebiet ehrlich gesagt auch nicht zu.
Bei der Technik und so traue ich unseren Providern schon was zu, die haben da nämlich gute Leute.
Allerdings Planungstechnik ist das echt unter aller Sau, was wir in Deutschland treiben, was Breitbandausbau angeht.
Was sagt das Beat-Brot? Obwohl Elektron natürlich sackt, finde ich Etcher schon geil,
weil es einfach straightforward-DD ist und nicht wie viele dummen Tools mit einem Bootleiter...
Ja, das stimmt schon. Etcher ist ganz praktisch. Allerdings kann man natürlich das Image auch einfach drauf-DD'en.
So, ich muss jetzt mal auf meinem Router, wie das Cisco Leute nennen, nachschauen,
was für eine IP mein Raspberry gekriegt hat.
Ein Rauder. Was sagt der Router denn? Der sagt, der ACP-Server ließ es.
Der sagt, dass mein Raspberry keine IP gekriegt hat, was schlecht ist.
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen? Ach doch, hier!
1, 2, 1 hat er gekriegt. Okay, die IP hatte schon mal jemand.
Weißt du, wie die ganze Zeit war? Gibt es da eigentlich einen ordentlichen Befehl für? Ich lösche das jetzt einfach.
Also ich könnte die einzelne Datei löschen, die einzelne Zeile löschen, aber ich will die eine ausgesehen nicht.
So, gut. Raspberry. Ja, das ist der richtige.
Kein Gesinger, please. Schau mal bitte, was ich hier gerade geweetet habe.
Ist gerade schlecht. Sebaro, das ist gut. Wartet mal.
Sebaros Twitter-Trends. Blablabla. Vierter Trend Hoden.
Ich hab da auch nur drüber gewittert, weil ich es bei mir auch in den Trends drin hatte.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, warum hab ich Hoden als Twitter-Trends?
Okay, gut. Was meinst du, wie wird das neue Cod? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab mir dazu noch überhaupt nichts angeguckt.
Doch, stimmt nicht. Den ersten Trailer hab ich mir angeguckt.
Was soll er kennen ob Spieler? Verdammt. Verdammt. Was ist das für ein scheiß aus dem Englisch übersetzter Titel?
Ist mir jetzt auch egal, was das neue Cod macht. Mal gucken.
Ich find's ja schon wieder komisch, dass es Modern Warfare ist, ohne dass Modern Warfare da dransteht.
Ohne dass da Zahl dransteht.
Ich watz ab.
Okay, wir sind aus dem Raspberry drauf. Wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Update.
Kann man eigentlich auf dem Raspberry nach der Neuinstallation nie was verkehrt machen, wenn man ein Update macht.
Dann müsste ich mal meine Standard-Tools installieren, die ich auf jedem Linux installiere.
Sobald ich mich das auf jedem Linux-System, oder auf nahezu jedem Linux-System installiere.
Wenn ich mich das erstmal einlogge.
Wenn der Raspberry sich dazu bequemt hat, jetzt weiterzumachen.
Auf.
Install T-Max, Wim, Dis, D, Start, H, Top und Git. Muss überall drauf.
Brauchen wir immer.
Kannst du mir die Seite von Cod mal linken? Ich hab mir überhaupt nichts angeguckt.
Ich hab hier nur irgendwie in der Google News Suche einfach mal Modern Warfare eingegeben. Das war's.
So, wir könnten eigentlich schon mal die Steckdosenleiste auspacken, während der Update geht.
Ja. Kogi.
Die Kogi-Qualitätsverpackung ist am Start.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich es wirklich, auch wenn es jetzt irgendwie so angehört hat, will ich es schlecht machen.
Mein Headset hört sich wieder anders an als vorher.
Die Verpackung und die Leiste an sich, so irgendwie, machen einen ganz stabilen Eindruck.
So, haben wir mal ein Upgrade und lassen den mal durchlaufen.
Weil nicht, dass wir am Ende irgendwelche Fehler haben, die schon längst gefixt sind, weil wir unseren Raspberry nicht aktualisiert haben.
So, ich pack die mal aus, die Leiste jetzt.
Also, die Verpackung fühlt sich schon mal ordentlich an.
Nicht so, wie manch Manchina-Crab, den es so gibt.
So, holen wir mal die Kogi-Kleiste raus und schmeißen die Verpackung weg.
Schmeißen die andere Verpackung auch noch weg.
Natürlich wieder massig, massig Plastik und Zeugs drum, so wie es für das Manchina-Zeug gehört.
So, also ich muss euch echt sagen, die Leiste macht einen stabilen und relativ hochwertigen Eindruck.
Hätte ich jetzt gar nicht erwartet bei so einem unter 30 Euro China-Produkt.
Neben ist natürlich noch mehr Plastik drauf, weil China-Produkte nie genug Plastik haben können.
Es ist ja auch unglaublich wichtig, dass man die Steckdosenleiste, nachdem sie schon in einem Karton ist, in dem Karton steckt,
in dem eine Tüte steckt, dass man die dann nochmal umwickelt mit Plastik.
Das ist natürlich ganz, ganz unglaublich wichtig.
Könnte ja was passieren sonst.
Achso, link zur Steckdose.
Ja, da, so reinfach nach Kogi.
Falls der Sebaro noch da ist.
Nee, vergiss es, wir machen keinen Link, weil wenn schon, dann machen wir den RefLink.
Ich generiere jetzt mal nebenbei einen RefLink.
Ich habe schon lange keinen Amazon-RefLink mehr generiert.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das geht.
Amazon-RefLink.
Aha.
Easy Money, easy life.
Hallo Maximilian, Accounts.
Sign out.
Sign in.
Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz auf den...
Erforderliche Überprüfung.
Sende in einen Code per E-Mail zu, überprüft Ihre Identität.
Ach komm.
Okay, das mit dem RefLink generieren wird tatsächlich schwierig.
Weil ich mich jetzt noch einloggen darf per Mail.
Sign in.
Egal, das kriegen wir hin, wir können eh nichts machen solange der Raspberry installiert.
So, Gmail eingeloggt.
Amazon.
Ihr Code, Ihr Code läuft ab.
Bitte bestätigen Sie Ihren Code.
Wir bestätigen unseren Code.
So, jetzt haben wir den Code bestätigt.
Und jetzt sagen wir Text erstellen, Textlink erstellen.
Kogeek.
Und jetzt gibt es den...
Einen niceen RefLink gibt es jetzt.
Den kann der Sebaro als Kommando machen.
Einen niceen Sellout RefLink.
Ja.
Bam.
Da ist er.
Allerdings, ich würde es mal abwarten.
Also, ich kann zu der Steckdose nichts sagen.
Ich hab die gerade zum ersten Mal ausgepackt und flash die jetzt.
Nein, das hier gleich, entweder ist Smoker Smoke angesagt oder es funktioniert einfach.
Oder das Flaschen funktioniert nicht oder was auch immer, man weiß ja nicht.
Okay, der Raspberry ist der Meinung, er ist fertig.
Dann rebooten wir den mal.
Wenn er wieder da ist, legen wir mal los mit der ganzen Geschichte.
Kam eigentlich früher viel bei deinem RefLink oder G2A rum?
Ja, ungefähr 1000 Euro im Monat.
Ich kann es jetzt ja sagen, es ist jetzt ja nichts...
Nicht mehr irgendwie gebunden da, nichts mehr zu erzählen.
Je nach Verkäufen im Monat auch mehr.
Das war Festbetrag plus Affiliate.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen, wenn ich mit meiner schon poplichen Größe auf YouTube
im Vergleich zu anderen, die es mittlerweile in Deutschland gibt,
die schon 1K von G2A kriegt im Monat,
können davon ausgehen, dass große Channels allein mit sowas wahrscheinlich locker nur hinten dranhängen,
die mehrere solcher Geschichten haben, wo sie an die 10K im Monat kriegen.
Und international will ich es mal gar nicht rechnen.
International reden wir da wahrscheinlich über Beträge, die einer im Leben nicht verdient.
Ja, Trebolon, die machen richtig Asche.
Viele auf YouTube tun manchmal so nach dem Motto,
ah, endlich kann ich davon leben und ich kann meinen Traum leben und sonst was.
Okay, man muss sagen, wirklich betrifft das natürlich nur wenige und das ist auch so.
Aber es ist nicht irgendwie, dass die jetzt irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen oder so,
ab einer gewissen Größe.
Es ist eigentlich, wenn man sich mal überlegt, also Spendengelder sind definitiv
bei anderen Leuten besser aufgehoben als bei großen YouTubern.
Ich meine, ich will es keinem ausreden jetzt beispielsweise,
ich weiß gar keinen Namen, ist ja egal, irgendwie seinen Lieblings-YouTuber zu unterstützen.
Allerdings, wenn er eine gewisse Größe hat,
kann er davon ausgehen, die Kohle braucht er eigentlich nicht.
Dann gibt es jemanden, einen kleineren YouTuber-Streamer, den ihr mögt.
Oder wenn ihr wirklich sagt, ich will das Geld für was sinnvolles ausgeben,
dann sucht euch irgendwas, ja sag mal, irgendwas Soziales bei euch in der Nähe.
Ich will es jetzt nicht sagen, geht zu irgendeiner Hilfsorganisation oder so.
Sucht euch irgendwas Lokales in der Nähe, sucht euch ein Tierheim oder sowas in der Richtung raus,
was euch am Herzen liegt und spendet dafür Kohle.
Die können das Geld in der Regel deutlich besser gebrauchen,
wie ein großer YouTuber. Für einen großen YouTuber ist,
auch wenn es eine große Spende ist, ich will nicht sagen, dass er sich nicht drüber freut,
aber für den ist es, war mal einfach ein Beispiel,
wenn ihr an euer lokales Tierheim 500 Euro spendet,
ist das für die richtig viel Geld, wovon die richtig viel machen können.
Wenn ihr einen großen YouTuber oder Streamer 500 Euro spendet,
dann sagt er sich nice und fertig.
Fertig. Was ist das für ein Linux, was du benutzt?
Manjaro mit i3-WM.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Ach so, wir haben unseren Raspberry neu gestartet.
Ich muss nochmal ein neues Passwort vergeben.
Mein komischer Copy-and-Paste-Tick ist schon schlimm, oder?
Ich brauche mal ein neues Passwort, muss ich mir jetzt mal ausdenken.
Neues Passwort ist Raspberry, neues Passwort ist irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
So, und ganz wichtig, Copy ID, damit ich mich in Zukunft
auf die Kiste einloggen kann, ohne Key. Ist eh das erste,
was ich immer auf eine neue Linux-Kiste machen würde.
Atmen, Atmener. Wäre schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Okay, also dann gucken wir uns mal die Anleitung an für die Steckdosenleiste,
was wir machen müssen.
A warning! Sicher sein, dass wir das verstehen, was hier passiert.
Naja, das habe ich aufgegeben, bei den meisten Sachen schon.
Da kommt sie ja zu nichts.
Selbst, selbst wenn wir eine der Steckdosenleisten
Monka-Smoken oder Prickens, ne man muss sich mal überlegen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn wir eine Steckdosenleiste pricken sollen.
Wir reden von einer Steckdosenleiste, ja.
Früher hat man gesagt, ich habe mein Smartphone geprickt,
als ich irgendwie Jail-Dingsen, wie heißt es, Jail-Breaken wollte
oder irgendwie beim Flaschen von einem Custom-Rom.
Aber nein, heute prickt man seine Steckdosenleiste.
Okay, checken wir das Repo aus. Ich mache das Ganze mal als Root.
Normalerweise ist es natürlich nicht empfehlenswert, alles als Root zu machen,
aber es sieht mir sehr danach aus, als müsste man Root sein dafür.
Okay, blablabla, Start, Flash, Stopp, Install, Prick Brirack.
Früher, Smartphone, keine Ahnung, vor 10 Jahren oder so,
war das schon halbwegs verbreitet.
Ey, vor 10 Jahren hat man noch seine Steckdosenleiste nicht geflasht.
Das ist erst so seit 2, 3 Jahren, seitdem alles IoT ist und China Cloud hat.
Ach ja, natürlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind, nachdem wir unsere Steckdosenleiste geflasht haben,
weil es Choose My Name gerade sagt, können wir natürlich dann auch unsere Steckdosenleiste regelmäßig updaten.
Mit neuen Tasmota-Versionen.
Ja, Eax, smartes Steckdosenleiste.
Eax, du hast wieder Eax, Sachen gibt es.
Ich glaube es ja nicht.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Bad Company 3 aus?
Kommt das jetzt 2020? Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe vorhin einen Gerücht gehört,
dass es angeblich mit dem Release der PS5 kommt, was dann 2020 wäre.
Max, kannst du mal dafür sorgen, dass Battlefield Erfindungs läuft?
Ja, würde Battlefield mittlerweile noch auf Steam rauskommen,
dann wäre die Chance gut, dass Valve dafür sorgt, dass das passiert.
Ich denke, dass es nicht auf Steam rauskommt.
Aber vielleicht hat man mal Battlefield 5 Glück mit einer Kombination aus Proton und Wein.
Müssen wir mal schauen, ob das vielleicht funktioniert.
Schauen wir doch gerade mal, während das hier installiert, wie es für Battlefield aussieht.
Watch Battlefield 5 Multiplayer running flawlessly on a Linux-Maschine.
Battlefield 5 works great in Linux.
Also die Chancen scheinen ja gar nicht mal schlecht zu sein, dass das auch funktionieren wird.
Ah, es ist auf Vulkan-Basis.
Das wird es erklären, weil die meisten Games, die auf Vulkan basieren,
zau-mäßig gut auf Proton- und Steam-Play-mäßig laufen.
Wo war denn jetzt noch mal der Unterschied?
Es gab doch irgendwie zwei verschiedene Varianten, wie du mit Steam Spiele laufen lassen kannst.
Drei Varianten gab es doch irgendwie unter Linux, wie man Spiele laufen lassen kann mit Steam.
Einmal gibt es eine richtig echte Linux-Version davon, dann wird die genommen.
Dann gibt es diese Proton-Frickelgeschichte und dann gibt es noch irgendeine Zwischenschicht.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, Spielen unter Linux ist eine Sache, die habe ich eigentlich schon vor 15 Jahren aufgegeben.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Aber Spielen unter Linux habe ich aufgegeben.
Das hört ja schon damit auf.
Ich meine, es mag zwar vieles gut funktionieren mittlerweile,
aber so richtig gut wird das unter Linux nie funktionieren.
Das liegt vor allem an einem Punkt, wenn man Multiplayer-Spiele spielt.
Multiplayer-Spiele haben alle Anti-Cheat drin und Multiplayer-Spiele, die kein Anti-Cheat haben,
so etwas wie COD, kannst du halt vergessen, weil das funktioniert nicht.
Die meisten Anti-Cheat-Hersteller sind nicht gerade scharf darauf, Linux zu unterstützen,
zumal das natürlich auch ein Einfallstor für Cheats eben ist, wenn du quasi das Spiel noch mit einer Zwischenschicht laufen lässt
oder unter Linux laufen lässt oder emuliert laufen lässt.
Und Competitive Games unter Linux-Multiplayer-Spielen, glaube ich, wird nie ein Ding sein.
Was ist denn der Vorteil von Linux gegenüber Windows? Zum Spielen gar nicht.
Für alles andere, Netzwerkgeschichten programmieren oder so was, ist das Leben einfach viel einfacher unter Linux.
Ich meine, das beste Beispiel, was es dafür gibt, ich finde, das ist ein Beispiel, das trifft eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Wenn ich unter Linux gucken will, ob ein Port offen ist bei einem Server, bei Google,
da sage ich telnet google.de 80. Da sehe ich, aha, port 80 ist offen.
Gut, wer hätte sich gedacht, dass port 80 auf Google auf ist?
Damit ich das gleiche unter Windows machen kann, muss ich mich erstmal, kennt ihr das? Soll ich es euch mal zeigen?
Oder kennt ihr das? Ich zeige es mal.
Also, damit ich telnet, ich habe es mittlerweile hier schon erzählt, damit ich so etwas einfaches wie telnet unter Windows benutzen kann,
muss ich erstmal sagen, ja, eine gute Frage, was muss ich überhaupt sagen?
Einstellungen, System, ne, wo installiert man Software?
Siehste, da fängt es schon an.
Okay, ich suche einfach mal danach hier, add or remove programs, muss ich hin, unter was wäre das denn zu finden gewesen jetzt?
Apps and features. So, dann sage ich, manage optional features, dann muss ich mein Rootpasswort eingeben,
weil, dann bin ich falsch, dann bin ich falsch.
Siehst du mal, ich kriege noch nicht mal hin und geschalt, unter Windows telnet zu installieren.
Was heißt doch features?
Ja, turn Windows features on und off. Ich vermute mal, das ist noch im alten Systempanel drinne.
Und dann muss ich gehen unter telnet client installieren.
Capture Card ist gestorben. Oh, okay.
Moment. Wann ist es verreckt?
Moment, ich muss mal die, ich muss das Display Capture nochmal neu starten.
Mein Display Capture geht nicht mehr.
Moment, Moment Leute, ich hab's gleich.
Ach, okay, als der Urprompt kam, na, super.
Moment Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das jetzt wieder hinkriege.
Kann es sein, dass es überhaupt ziemlich kaputt ist?
Ja, genau, MonkaS.
Also, Display Capture an und aus bringt nichts.
Okay, Moment, Moment. Capture, das muss doch funktionieren.
Display Capture 3.
Ich kann mein fucking Display nicht mehr capturen.
Alter, Windows, ey.
Dann capture ich jetzt die 4M.
Capture jetzt die 4M, das wird doch funktionieren.
Window Capture, 4M bei Workstation.
So, seht ihr was?
Was gleich groß?
Schaltet sich das jetzt automatisch groß, oder?
Ah, jetzt ist aber zu viel drauf.
Ja, Windows hast du gut gemacht.
So, jetzt funktioniert's wieder, na.
Ihr müsst mich jetzt mal dran erinnern.
Sollte ich jetzt mal ins Windows rüber wechseln und irgendwas zeigen wollen, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Ich remove hier nochmal mein Display Capture, ich guck mal kurz, ob das wieder funktioniert.
Video Capture, Window Capture, Game Capture, Display Capture.
Mehr gibt's nicht.
Nee, funktioniert echt nicht.
Es ist irgendwie kaputt gegangen. Na toll.
Na gut, da müssen wir jetzt mit Window Capture leben.
Na gut, man sieht schon mal, unter Linux mach ich Telnet, Google und das funktioniert.
Und unter Windows schieß ich mein OBS ab.
Also falls ihr irgendwas nicht seht und ich irgendwas von wegen jetzt hier in Windows rumklicke, dann sagt mir mal Bescheid, dass ich nur noch Window Capture hab und ihr gar nicht seht, wenn ich jetzt ins Windows reihe.
Also wenn ich in Windows wechsle, dann seht ihr dann nur, dass das Fenster kleiner wird.
Und sobald das Fenster kleiner wird, müsst ihr im Chat schreien, da macht's hier, wir sehen nix.
Okay, also wir sind auf Raspberry drauf.
Wir haben den ganzen Krempel installiert, wir haben die Voraussetzungen auch installiert.
So, wie geht's denn jetzt weiter?
Start, Flash.
Bin ja mal gespannt, was jetzt passiert, ob das funktioniert.
Ich mein, ich hab die Steckdosenleiste noch nicht mal angeschlossen.
Vielleicht sollte ich vorher mal ins Handbuch von der Steckdosenleiste gucken.
Äh, Luciano fragt, ja okay, verstehe, also ist Linux eher was für Programmierer, für Otto Normalverbraucher gibt es keinen Unterschied.
Oh doch, es gibt für Otto Normalverbraucher einen riesen Unterschied. Otto Normalverbraucher kommt mit Linux in der Regel nicht klar.
Otto Normalverbraucher kommt in der Regel mit Linux überhaupt nicht klar.
Das liegt aber gar nicht so sehr an Otto Normalverbraucher direkt, weil er zu blöd wäre.
Und das liegt auch gar nicht so sehr an Linux auf dem Desktop.
Wohlgemerkt, Linux ist übelst Mainstream, überall anders als auf dem Desktop.
Sondern es liegt eigentlich daran, dass die meisten Leute mit Windows anfangen, dann angepisst sind von Windows und sagen, so, jetzt steige ich auf Linux um.
Und dann mit der Erwartung dran gehen, dass sie im Prinzip ihr Windows-Wissen transferieren können auf ihre Linux-Installation.
Das funktioniert nicht. Das ist einfach grundsätzlich komplett anders aufgebaut als Windows.
Tellen dann auf Google, ich wollte einfach nur zeigen, wie man gucken kann, ob ein Port auf ist.
Ja genau, viele programmieren gerne unter Mac, weil du halt das ganze Zeug auch nachinstallieren kannst.
Allerdings, bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es so, dass ganz viele mittlerweile komplett auf Linux umgestiegen sind zum entwickeln.
Sowohl Web-Entwickler als auch unsere Java-Leute.
Viele haben natürlich Windows, weil es vorgeschrieben ist, klar.
Was können die Steckdosen eigentlich, dass sie eine Cloud brauchen?
Man kann sie remote schalten und jede Menge anderen smarten Cloud-Features verwenden, die ich aber nicht verwenden will.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz ins Handbuch gucken. Ich gucke mal bei Amazon, ob es das Handbuch da gibt, dass wir uns das Handbuch zusammen angucken können.
Gibt es da ein PDF?
Manual. Nein, natürlich nicht.
CoGeek-Manual.
Die haben tatsächlich eine Webseite. CoGeek. Und das hat auch das gleiche Logo.
Und das sind alles so Retorten-Geräte. Ja, wo ist die Steckdose? Da ist sie.
Die Klohe. Klohe 4.
Manual.
Ich kann es nicht fassen, dass die Chinesen wirklich...
Was heißt das?
TDWZ.
Okay.
Open.
Okay, das sieht natürlich sehr vertrauenserweckend aus jetzt.
Klohe 4.
Smart Power Strip.
Genau, das ist die Anleitung, die ich hier auch habe.
Also.
Die haben einfach eins zu eins die Mini-Seiten des PDF geklatschte.
Okay, da sind USB-Ports. Das kann ich bestätigen. Da sind USB-Ports.
Da sind Electrical Outlets. Das kann ich auch bestätigen.
Hier ist ein On-Off-Port. Das ist bei mir auch so. Und das Ganze ist der Power Strip. Ja.
Plug.
Ach ja, für die Steckdose.
Power Button. On-Off.
Was ich immer interessant finde, mittlerweile sind sogar die englischen Handbücher bei den Chinasachen gar nicht so scheiße.
Ist das auf einem Raspberry oder hast du Linux auf deinem Windows drauf gespielt?
Das ist eine Linux VM. Das ist Manjaro Linux mit I3. Das hier ist der Raspberry.
Da putt PSSH drauf.
Wo gerade dabei sind, ich starte das mal im T-Max.
Falls das in irgendeiner Art und Weise abkacken sollte.
Dass das da bleibt.
Zieler Konfiguration.
Okay, hier geht es los. Specifications.
Ach, das ist für USB. Ich wollte gerade sagen. Okay, kannst du schon mal Quick-Chargen mit. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Kannst du schon mal theoretisch Quick-Chargen mit.
10 Ampere, das ist so die Standard-Sache, die du über so einen Stecker machen darfst.
Die kleinen Euro-Stecker sind glaube ich bis 2.
Und die großen sind irgendwie bis 10 oder was? Bis 16? Nee, 16, der Flo, genau. 16 sind es.
So, es kann nur 2,4 Gigahertz WLAN.
Was ehrlich gesagt scheißegal ist. Also vollkommen wurscht.
Ich meine mittlerweile ist 5 eigentlich so das für neuere Geräte.
Einfach weil es da ein bisschen leerer ist im Frequenzbereich.
Aber es ist vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn ihr auf 2,4 Gigahertz läuft.
Before you begin.
Ja ja, wir perren das eh nicht mit der offiziellen App. Das können sie vergessen.
Okay, wir sollen die Free CoGeek Live App endloggen.
Machen wir schon mal nicht. Wissen wir das, wenn wir das machen.
Ach Leute, seht ihr überhaupt jetzt, ihr seht jetzt ja gar nicht mehr die Overlay-Emotes.
Ich emote mir hier einen ab.
Ja, aber ihr seht die ja gar nicht mehr, weil wir Window-Capture haben.
Oh, das ist ja echt viel Pepehands.
Dann muss ich jetzt so emoten.
Okay, was mich interessiert ist, wie ich das Ding in den Pairing-Modus versetzen kann.
Open CoGeek Live App, Tab, Add Devices.
Ah ja, hier.
Press and hold on off button of the device for 5 seconds until indicator light flashes quickly.
Das werden wir gleich machen, nachdem wir das gestartet haben.
Ja, der Rest ist für uns egal.
Lifetime-Technical Support.
Das müssen wir gerade mal ausprobieren, oder?
Wir müssen jetzt eigentlich gerade mal hingehen
und CoGeek irgendwelche doofen Fragen stellen zu der Steckdosenleiste.
Mal probieren, ob das funktioniert mit Lifetime-Technical Support.
Customer Service.
Is it safe to use the CoGeek Claw 4,
in the best room for my new smart toilet?
MonkaSmoke.
Okay, vorne, da fällt immer eine Adresse.
Ich brauche eine Fake-Email-Adresse, aber die kann ich jetzt nicht on stream machen.
Wir machen jetzt erst mal weiter.
E-Mail-Generator, ja.
Ja, wenn man sieht es dann on stream.
Ich gucke jetzt erst mal, ob ich die überhaupt geflasht kriege.
Okay, also was sollen wir machen?
Wir sollen jetzt Startflash eingeben.
Das kriegen wir gerade so noch hin.
Omega-Lol-and-Mail-LU.
Welches Desktop environment verwendest du?
Das ist Manjaro Linux mit i3-WM.
Flasht du mal eine Katze, wenn du eine China-Katze hast?
Eine China-Staubsauger-Roboter in Katzenform.
Dann flashen wir auch eine Katze.
So, Startflash. Oh, es geht los.
Develop bei Michael Steigerwald.
From V-Trust.
Mit Merlin Schuhmacher.
So.
Vom CT-Magazin.
Okay, also was macht das Ding?
Jetzt erklären sie uns, wie das funktioniert.
Und wir sollen das carefully readen.
Also, natürlich, so wie wir das machen,
nachdem wir ja immer jegliche Handbücher sehr aufmerksam lesen,
gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Verwendest du eigentlich Open Hub oder ähnliches?
Ich hab Home Assistant.
Open Hub ist mir zu viel Java.
Also, was macht Tuya Converters?
Erzeugt einen Access Point, oder?
Nee, irgendwas stand doch da gerade.
Fake Update Server Envye.
Okay, das Gaucheln im Ding war sie irgendwie vor,
wir haben bei uns lokal eine China Cloud installiert.
Es backup die Firmware.
Und dann kann ich eine Alternative Firmware installieren.
In dem Fall, was wir wollen, ist Tasmota.
6.5, das neueste.
Und ohne, dass man an die Kontakte dran muss und löten über Wireless.
Ja, und wir sind uns natürlich über die Konsequenzen vollkommen im Klaren.
Monka Smoke.
Also, falls das abkackt, dann haben wir Pech.
Machste nix.
Flashing in alternate can, unexpected device behavior.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, solange es nicht abfackelt, ist alles in Ordnung.
Own risk.
Ja, komm.
Yes.
Man.
Was?
Ah, ich muss Yes kleinschreiben.
Okay.
Yes.
Starting AP in screen.
Stop any Apache Server.
Okay, also, was soll das sein?
Connect any device to the Wi-Fi power trust flash.
Connect.
Moment.
Jedes.
Okay.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Handy.
Leute.
Moment.
Wir machen noch was anderes.
Wir brechen das Ganze noch mal ab.
Wie gut.
Muss erst noch was machen auf dem Raspberry vorher.
Demnlich, wir müssen auf dem Raspberry noch einen Chrome oder einen Firefox in Celeron
X Forwarding machen.
Weil, es bringt ja nix, wenn ich auf meinem Handy den ganzen Scheiß mach und ihr seht's
nicht.
Und der Raspberry ist in dem gleichen Netzwerk drinne, wie die Steckdose.
Hoffe ich mal zumindest.
Und dann kann ich mit dem Raspberry auf die Steckdose.
Und ihr seht was.
Mit dem Raspberry über per X Forwarding über SSH auf dem Raspberry mit einem Chrome auf
die Steckdose.
Ich hoffe, man hat's jetzt verstanden.
So.
Und mal gucken.
Deswegen müssen wir erst mal einen Chrome installieren.
Chrome.
Chrome ist immer ganz schön fett.
Kona Chrome.
So.
Auf Chrome installiere ich mal.
Oh nee.
Nee, sehbaro.
Bloß nicht auf meine YouTube-E-Mail-Adresse weiterleiten.
Da guck ich nicht rein.
Ich sag dir nachher in die E-Mail-Adresse, wo du es drauf weiterleiten kannst.
Mal mal nach dem Streben.
Ich sag's dir nach dem Streben.
Ah Jasper, du hast das schon mal gemacht.
Ja, mal gucken.
Sag doch im Stream.
Nee.
So ein paar Sachen erzähle ich nicht im Stream.
Obwohl ich bin nicht die E-Mail-Adresse, die ich normalerweise verwende.
Sehr bescheuert, das im Stream zu erzählen.
Kennt jemand noch die YouTube-PNs?
Ah ja, das war die Zeiten, wo man noch ordentlich auf YouTube kommunizieren konnte.
Wo YouTube noch sowas wie eine Inbox hatte.
Wo man Kommentare lesen konnte.
Und wo YouTube noch Paging hatte anstatt Endless-Scroll.
Heute Endless-Scroll ist der größte Scheiß in der Webentwicklung der letzten fünf Jahre.
Bob der Panzerfahrer, genau.
Spielst du eigentlich noch was in letzter Zeit, Max?
Tja, in letzter Zeit gerade wenig, ja.
Die ganze Zeit schon am Überlegen, was ich spielen könnte.
Ich habe mir auch ein paar Sachen runtergeladen, aber nie wirklich, wirklich gespielt.
Es gibt auch gerade kein Game, was mich so richtig begeistert.
Hast du irgendwas eher gesagt, was du gerade spielst?
Spielst du noch Apex?
Apex hat ja auch ein bisschen, auch während Prom installiert, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Apex ist ja auch ein bisschen eingebrochen, ne?
Was ist die schlechteste Eigenschaft, die ein Informatiker haben kann?
Ach, ich glaube, das ist die gleiche Eigenschaft, die eigentlich alle anderen Leute auch haben können.
Nämlich sich zu geil zu finden.
Das gibt es durch die Bankwerk überall Leute, die sich einfach viel zu geil finden.
Und es eigentlich nicht gerechtfertigt ist.
Also Apex ist hier nicht mehr angesagt, ne?
Doch, hier unten.
Guck mal, Apex hat weniger als...
Warum hat denn Overwatch auf einmal so viele Zuschauer?
Was ist denn da los?
Ach so, Seagull ist on.
Ja, sonst hat es nämlich auch keine Zuschauer.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert, wo die alle hin sind.
Wo die auf einmal herkommen.
Also Apex ist wahrscheinlich dizzy online oder so mit 6k und der Rest nicht.
Oder auch nicht.
Fortnite macht da so... Was ist denn? Teamfight Tactics.
Okay, Forza streamed.
Forza, Lyra, Crack, Forza...
Okay, allein schon von den drei und die hier zusammen.
Da hast du ja schon halb twitch quasi abgefrühstückt damit.
Das ist locker gesponsert. Wahrscheinlich, wenn die das alle streamen.
Oder es ist irgendwie so ein Survival Game.
Die sind ja, wenn sie neu sind, also irgendwie so ein Early Access Survival Game.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist Auto Chess von LOL. Ach so.
Ah, okay. Ja, Auto Chess ist zurzeit auch sehr angesagt.
Auto Chess ist auch sehr angesagt, ja.
Noch nicht gespielt, aber schon ein paar Mal gesehen, das ist sehr angesagt.
Ah, ist fertig installieren.
Also jetzt mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wenn ich den Chrome aufmache.
Auf meinem Raspberry.
Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen, das ist nicht allzu schnell.
Chrome X Forwarding.
Aber es funktioniert, ne?
Man sieht schon, es ist Arschlamm, aber es funktioniert.
Das ist jetzt quasi ein Chrome, der auf meinem Raspberry läuft.
Allerdings die Ausgabe bei mir lokal ist.
Und das sind übrigens auch so Spielrenzchen, die unter Windows gar nicht so einfach sind.
Unter Windows hast du RDP und das Mars.
Und jetzt mal ernsthaft, oder wie der Kabum damals sagen würde, Hand aufs Herz.
Was würdet ihr lieber aufmachen nach außen?
Wenn es das H-Port oder RDP?
Ganz ernst gemeine Frage.
Wo könntet ihr persönlich ruhiger schlafen?
Wenn RDP nach außen auf ist oder wenn es das H nach außen auf ist?
RDP ist klar.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch laggy team.
Molita, Vaku.
Man muss das auch nicht wissen.
RDP kennen die meisten, das ist Remote Desktop unter Windows.
Und SSH ist quasi Kommando-Zeilenzugang, Remote für Linux.
Allerdings kann man über SSH auch grafische Programme starten, aber dann nicht so schnell.
Okay, Chrome funktioniert.
Müssen wir mal einen T-Max auf.
Können wir immer einen Chrome starten.
Nebenbei machen wir ein neues Tab auf.
Und gehen mal wieder in dieses Trio-Convert rein und starten den Kram wieder.
Was muss bei eigentlichem Start-Flash war das Richtige, ne?
Okay, Start-Flash.
Bam.
Das haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Okay, connect any other device.
Mach ich.
Ich connecte mal mein iPhone.
Flash me if you can.
iPhone sollte joinen jetzt.
iPhone ist gejoined, okay.
Put your IoT device in auto-config pairing mode.
Jetzt müssen wir das machen, was im Handbuch drinne stand.
Nämlich den Startknopf holden for 5 seconds, bis es quickly flashes.
Bester Satz, oder?
Okay, ich muss mal kurz an die Steckdose, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset ausziehen.
Dann knöpft ihr das rein und holdet es, bis es quickly flashes.
Da wechselt es schon mal in die China-Qualität.
Okay, sobald du es einschaltest, sobald du es einschaltest, macht es...
Ah, hier, hört mal.
Sehr gut, wir holden das.
Flash, okay.
Es flasht, enter.
Macht das jetzt was?
Es flasht nicht mehr quickly.
Das sieht nicht so aus, als funktioniert das.
Aber es ist aus, es flasht nicht mehr.
Vielleicht gleich, gleich kommt Morka-Smoke.
Ja, ja, genau, so meinte ich das.
Damit man den Black Ops 4 auf dem PC zusammenspielen konnte,
musste man übrigens noch Ports forwarden.
Und das im 2019.
Oh, es hat funktioniert.
IOT-Device ist online.
IP 10-42-42-42.
Pock.
Es hat einen abartigen Speed, die es flasht.
Mit 12 Kb oder so in der Sekunde.
Genau, es überschreibt mir jetzt die iPhone-Firma.
Nicht schlimm ist das iPhone von der Firma.
Kann ich dann am Dienstag sagen, also irgendwie ist das iPhone,
iPhone ist mir, keine Ahnung, mit Office drüber gefahren.
Geht nicht mehr, geht nicht mehr.
Okay.
Flash-Third-Party.
Go back to original Software.
Nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Conversion, okay, das sollen wir jetzt checken.
Checken wir das mal.
Voice is already booting from user space.
Okay, was machen wir jetzt?
Basic build of das Motor 6.5 is already included.
Das kann man damit flashen.
Dann flashen wir das doch.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt der kritische Punkt.
Wenn es dabei abkackt, ist es geprickt.
What's up, gleich schaut mein Chef wieder zu.
Das könnte, also potenziell ist es tatsächlich möglich,
dass mein Chef zuguckt.
Der weiß, dass ich YouTube-Videos mache.
Der hat auch die ein oder andere Sachen schon geguckt.
Der weiß, dass ich Technik-Kram neuerdings auf Twitch streame.
Ich hab sogar irgendwo, irgendwo ganz tief in der Schublade
hab ich sogar noch einen Battlefield 3 Helikopter-Gameplay
von meinem Chef.
Damals war er aber noch nicht mein Chef.
Guck mal, das müsste ich echt mal ausbuddeln wieder.
PS3 Heli-Gameplay.
Okay Leute, wir flashen das jetzt.
Wir flashen jetzt ein aktuelles das Motor 6.5 drauf.
Device should flash and restart.
Aktuell macht das Ding nichts.
Das leuchtet schon die ganze Zeit nicht mehr.
Was ist das?
Warte, ich muss es euch mal ans Kopfhörer halten.
Das Relay spinnt gerade ein bisschen rum da drin.
Vielleicht möchte uns das Ding auch nur irgendwas sagen.
Okay.
Wie joinen wir mit dem Raspberry nochmal ein Netzwerk?
Okay, ich glaube den Raspberry kann ich neu starten, weil das...
Okay, den Raspberry starten wir mal neu.
Binibitor sagt, ich komm rein, seh den Titel und bin erst mal überfordert.
Was soll denn die Steckdose können, außer halt ein paar Volt und Ampere liefern,
wenn man rein langt?
Na ja, also rein langen hab ich jetzt nicht vor.
Das geht einfach darum, dass man die Steckdose remote schalten kann.
Also nicht nur mit dem Knopf, sondern dass ich die aus meiner Heimautomatisierung
schalten kann, ohne dass ich die China Cloud brauche, weil das ist Steckdose,
die funktioniert nur über eine Cloud in China normalerweise.
Und gerade eben habe ich sie geflashed mit Custom Firmware.
Und wir sind jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen am Rätsel, ob es jetzt funktioniert
oder ob es jetzt funktioniert hat oder nicht.
So, und jetzt...
Leute, ich muss mal kurz für das WLAN joinen, muss ich mal kurz ausmachen hier.
Anzeige ist raus.
Wir haben es gleich, wir haben es gleich.
Aber die WLANs hier und wie das alles heißt und eingerichtet,
muss ich jetzt unbedingt on stream zeigen.
Wie heißt denn das WLAN, was dieses Ding jetzt aufgemacht hat?
Ah ja, ich habe es.
Finish.
Okay, ich glaube, ich kann es wieder einschalten.
Ich schalte es wieder ein, Moment.
Okay, also was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist, ich habe nach WLANs gescannt
und ich habe mich verbunden zu dem WLAN, was die Steckdose aufgemacht hat.
Wieso zeigst du das denn nicht? Hast du was zu verbergen? Verfassungsschutz ist informiert.
Ja, jeder hat was zu verbergen.
So, was machen wir jetzt?
Jeder hat irgendwas, was einer nicht will, das man rauskriegt.
Manchmal ist es einfach so, dass man einfach stehen ergreifend nicht will,
dass man weiß, dass andere sehen, was man macht.
Die Skorpion-Paste.
Okay, das WLAN, das die Steckdose aufgemacht hat.
Es ist halt so abgetreten.
Okay, haben wir jetzt eine IP gekriegt für das WLAN?
Ja, hier, da, guckt mal. Nice.
Und ich wette mit euch, zumindest ist das glaube ich die Standard bei TAS Motor so,
dass auf dieser 4.1 das Standard WLAN läuft.
Das Gerät auf 1 ist immer. Oh, der Chrome Browser ist langsam.
Ja, wir sind eingeloggt auf unserer Steckdose. Wir haben es geschafft.
Gibt es die Firmen, die noch für andere Geräte? Ja, TAS Motor gibt es für fast alles.
Okay, WLAN kann ich euch, das hier kann ich es eingeben.
Man sieht das Passwort nämlich auch nicht.
Home.
Und ich muss mal nebenbei nachgucken.
Weil jetzt ist es auch kritisch, das habe ich in der Anleitung gelesen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier das falsche Passwort eingebe,
also wenn ich jetzt hier das falsche WLAN Passwort eingebe,
dann komme ich nicht mehr ans Gerät dran.
Das ist ziemlich blöd.
Deswegen gucke ich lieber nochmal nach, wie genau mein WLAN Passwort ist.
Das hätte ich mir schon mal verschrieben.
Nämlich Home ist die richtige. So und Passwort ist, zeigt mal her.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig geschrieben.
Wenn ich das nicht richtig geschrieben habe, ist wirklich kacke jetzt.
Ich schreibe es hier unten nochmal rein, ob es genau so lang ist.
Gleich lang, ja okay.
Das ist jetzt wirklich der MonkaS Moment.
Der Titel ist ernst gemeint, ja wir sind schon auf meiner Steckdose gerade.
Okay Leute, safe.
Okay, es ist neu gestartet und angegangen.
Ich gucke mal im DHCP Server, ob die Steckdose eine IP abgerufen hat.
Und dann gehen wir auf die Steckdose drauf und konfigurieren das Ding richtig.
Hoffentlich habe ich es richtig gemacht.
Sonst habe ich die Steckdose geprickt.
Kann ich mein iPhone eigentlich jetzt aus dem WLAN rausnehmen?
Der DHCP Server liest es.
Ha, da ist sie.
Oder? Nee.
Fuck, das ist eine andere.
Das ist eine andere Sonoff.
Hier.
Das hier kann zu.
Da ist sie. 1, 2, 2, 1, 6, 8.
Fuck, wo war es jetzt?
1, 1, 1, 6.
Bam, wir sind auf unserer Steckdoseleiste drauf.
Jetzt seht ihr die ganzen Emotes nicht.
Wir sind auf der Steckdoseleiste drauf.
Mit Custom Firmware.
Pock.
So, nun gut.
Jetzt müssen wir als erstes mal einrichten.
Ich versuche mal die Steckdosenleiste hier auf den Schreibtisch zu legen,
dass ihr das irgendwie hört.
Hoffentlich reicht das Kabel.
Oh, oh, ich sehe gerade sogar Gumminoppen unten dran, dass sie nicht rutscht.
Eine High Quality Billig Schienaleiste.
Aber sie rutscht trotzdem.
So, wenn ich jetzt hier on off mache, sollte zumindest schon mal Anschluss 1 an ausgehen.
Also.
Oh.
Toggl macht was ganz was anderes, als ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Toggl macht was ziemlich Merkwürdiges.
Toggl schaltet um zwischen erster und zweiter Dose.
Macht die erste ganz schnell aus an.
Ne, an aus und die zweite ganz schnell aus an.
Und wenn ich wieder Toggl drücke, die zweite aus und die erste an.
Oh, jetzt muss ich mal was ausprobieren.
Achtung, gleich gibt es MonkaS Smoke.
Ich glaube, das ist keine so gute Idee.
Ich habe echt Probleme.
Also, ich bin nicht mehr ganz dicht, was sowas angeht.
Sobald ich irgendwie so eine bescheuerte Idee habe, sowas zu machen, muss ich es auch gleich ausprobieren.
Ja, gut, aber nicht, dass es jetzt wirklich noch MonkaS Smoke gibt.
Okay, das heißt, ich brauche erst mal die richtige Pin Belegung für das Ding.
Und ich erinnere mich dran, dass irgendjemand bei Amazon hatte, glaube ich, was von Tasmota geschrieben.
Für die Verwendung mit Sonoff Tasmota als Modul Generic wähle und folgende Pinzuordnung treffe.
Aber bevor wir das dem jetzt einfach glauben, gucken wir nochmal Kogic, was das offizielle Tasmota Wiki zu Kogic sagt.
Wir sagen Kogic 4-Channel Wi-Fi Socket.
Es sieht zwar ein bisschen anders aus, aber ihr könnt euren Arsch drauf wetten, dass das unterm Gehäuse exakt das gleiche Ding ist.
So, und die hier haben nämlich auch drinne stehen.
Vierfach eins, was auch immer.
Also, Configuration, Modul, Modul und dann Generic 18.
Das ist sehr sprechend, ganz klar, Generic 18 müssen wir nehmen, was auch sonst.
Und dann stellen wir fest, dass das Generic 18 bei denen circa fünfmal so viele Pins hat wie bei uns.
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir neu starten.
Die Steckdose startet neu.
Ich gebe euch recht, es hört sich schon ein bisschen komisch an, wenn man sagt, die Steckdose rebootet.
Das hört sich schon ein bisschen merkwürdig an, aber in dem Fall ist es einfach so, die Steckdose rebootet.
Und jetzt hat die Steckdose rebootet.
Und jetzt haben wir auch mehr Einstellungsmöglichkeiten.
Okay, also was wir waren.
GPIO 0, none.
GPIO 1, Button, Button 1.
Button 1.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da einstelle, aber wenn es im offiziellen Wiki steht, wird das schon stimmen.
GPIO 2, nix.
GPIO 3, Lady, Lady 1.
Lady 1.
Quasi die First Lady.
Oh, das war schlecht.
GPIO 4, Relay 3.
GPIO 5, Relay 5.
Das ist ja mal zum einzigen Mal GPIO 5 und Relay 5, wo die Benamung irgendwie Sinn gibt bei dem China Kram.
Vor allem, warum ist es Relay 3 und Relay 5?
Warum?
Hat die RGB.
Also, die hat auf jeden Fall mehrere LEDs dran.
Ob man die irgendwie RGB-mäßig ändern kann, das müssen wir mal schauen, ja.
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ob wir das, ich meine, man kann hier schon mal...
Okay, RGB gibt es nicht.
Was muss ich da einstellen?
Lady 1e, ne?
Wir können ja mal danach gucken, ob das Motor irgendwie eine RGB-Control hat, ob man vielleicht wirklich RGB dran machen kann.
Okay, Relay 1, GPIO 12 wird Relay 1.
GPIO 13, Lady 1 wird Relay 4.
Warum sollte man auch das dran anschließen, nachdem es benannt ist?
Also, eine ordentliche China-Fabrik macht das nicht so.
GPIO 14 Sensor, Relay 2.
So, none, none.
Safe.
So, Achtung, ich halte euch mal dran, es ist Reboot, mal gucken, ob irgendwas passiert.
Es blinkt.
Oh, es blinkt, es blinkt, es blinkt irgendwie so, als will es sich, als will es sich eher perren wieder.
Ah, schau mal da.
Oh, oh, das stimmt aber nicht.
Oh.
Die Reihenfolge stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Ne.
Also, die Reihenfolge stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Also, die Reihenfolge ist nicht ganz richtig.
Also, der erste Schalter schaltet Dose 2.
Der zweite Schalter schaltet USB.
Der dritte Schalter schaltet Dose 3.
Okay, okay.
Ne, ne, wenn wir von vorne stehen, Dose 2.
Vier schaltet...
Wobei, das ist...
Ne, vier schaltet...
Fünf schaltet eins.
Vier schaltet vier.
Okay, vier ist richtig.
Das ist ja wieder ganz toll zugeordnet alles.
Da hat sich der Chinese wohl verlötet, würde ich mal sagen.
Ne, drei schaltet nicht drei.
Wenn man von vorne zählt, wovon ich jetzt...
Ich würde mal von rechts anfangen in dem Fall.
Von rechts nach links zählen.
Dann ist es Dose 2.
Ansonsten wäre es richtig, aber dafür wäre das hier falsch.
Okay.
Also, was können wir jetzt behalten?
Vier ist okay.
Fünf ist eins.
Oh, das ist mir zu kompliziert.
Okay, also vier stimmt.
Was muss man tauschen?
Fünf.
Ne, fünf muss ich mit eins tauschen.
Okay.
Ei, ei, ei.
Fünf muss ich mit eins tauschen.
Also, was?
Das auf zwei und das auf drei?
Na, vielleicht stimmt es ja auch, was der Amazon Dude geschrieben hat.
Ne, das ist noch was ganz anderes.
Wir haben es mit der Reihenfolge vom Löten nicht so in China.
Fünf schaltet jetzt schon mal fünf.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Vier schaltet eins.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt vier noch wechseln mit dem, der zwei schaltet.
Zwei schaltet zwei von der falschen Reihenfolge.
Das ist mir jetzt zu hoch.
Ich glaube, zwei und vier muss ich wechseln.
Ja.
Zwei und vier muss ich wechseln.
Da müsste es halbwegs stimmen.
Zwei und vier, also fünf und vier muss ich wechseln.
Das auf vier und das auf fünf.
Meine Güte.
Oh, hatte schon neu gestartet.
Das ging aber verdammt schnell.
Ne, ne, mach ich.
Okay, fünf.
Hä?
Warum um alles in der Welt hat sich fünf jetzt umgestellt?
Da habe ich doch überhaupt nichts dran gemacht.
Hä?
Habe ich?
Ne.
Habe ich nicht.
Was ist das hier unten?
Ja, ja, ich habe relay vier und fünf getauscht.
Aber ich meine, GPIO 14 ist eigentlich der, der vier, der der fünf schaltet.
Okay, also wir halten fest, prinzipiell funktioniert es.
Das schaltet komplett falsch jetzt.
Ich muss.
Hier muss ich noch tauschen.
Hier und fünf.
Also drei und fünf.
Fünf.
Drei.
Steckt uns in die Bange.
Hä, jetzt schaltet fünf auf einmal USB?
Was zum Teufel haben die da gemacht?
Das hat vorher nicht mal ansatzweise USB geschaltet.
Zwei haben vorher USB geschaltet.
Zwei schaltet jetzt vier?
Was zum Geier haben die da gemacht?
WTF?
Ja, das ist wirklich wie in so einem Super Nintendo RPG irgendwelche Schieberätsel.
Kannst du die Tasten nicht einfach umbenennen?
Ja, theoretisch schon, aber ich meine, ich muss jetzt, ich will es ja haben, dass es in der richtigen Reihen, also ich will ja, dass es von hinten nach vorne schaltet.
Also ich meine, ich glaube, hier im Webinterface kann ich es nicht umbenennen.
Ich meine, am Ende ist es nicht wirklich schlimm, muss man sagen, ja.
Am Ende ist es nicht wirklich schlimm, weil ich mache das eh in meiner Heimautomatisierung und da kriegt es einfach einen Namen dran.
Das heißt dann, keine Ahnung, Steckdose-3D-Drucker oder so, da muss ich einfach nur einmal gucken, dass es stimmt.
Japsa, ich habe ESPHome im Einsatz.
ESPHome ist allerdings nichts, was da einfach so auf eine Steckdosenleiste flasht.
ESPHome ist, wenn du selbst, wenn du dir deinen eigenen Controller kaufst und willst einen eigenen Sensor dran machen und willst einfach nur eine einfache Firmware haben,
die du recht einfach programmieren kannst oder konfigurieren kannst über ein YAML-File, dafür ist ESPHome gut.
Für sowas hier eher nicht so.
ESPHome selbst hat ja auch kein Webinterface, wo du schalten kannst.
Das hat halt seinen Control-Server oder so.
Nee, nee, hierfür ist TAS Motor schon die schönere Variante.
Okay, wisst ihr was, wir probieren jetzt einfach mal von diesem Amazon-Duty-Settings aus.
Und außerdem chat, jetzt tut man nicht so, als könnte ich was dafür, dass das falsch ist.
Ich meine, wenn du die Dinger tauschst, kommt absolut unvorhergesehener Schwachsinn bei raus.
Okay, der Typ sagt, GPIO 1, wir machen jetzt mal die Settings von dem Amazon-Typ.
GPIO 1 ist LED 1. GPIO 3 ist Button 1. GPIO 4 ist Relay 2.
Okay, GPIO 5 ist Relay 1. GPIO 12 ist Relay 3.
GPIO 13 ist Relay 4. Und GPIO 14 ist Relay 5. Okay, mal gucken, was jetzt rauskommt.
Ist sogar eine Sie. Oh ja, hier. Cornelia Manuela Schröter.
Hey, hey, das sieht gut aus. Oh, das ist ein nice Grill hier, die Manuela.
Funktioniert, ist die richtige Reihenfolge.
Funktioniert, zack. Vorne, erste von rechts an, zweite von rechts an, dritte von rechts an, vierte von rechts an.
Also, linke, und letzter aus USB. Sehr schön.
So Leute, und jetzt lade ich mal kurz mein Handy an dem USB-Ding auf.
Mal gucken, ob es wenigstens jetzt Monika Smoke gibt. Was ich nicht hoffen würde, weil das ist nicht mein Handy.
Also, wie gesagt, ist immer noch das iPhone von der Firma. Das will ich nicht unbedingt kaputt machen.
Aber ein gewisses Risiko muss ja sein, mit der China-Steckdose.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da was passiert. Also, wenn das halbwegs USB-konform ist, passiert da nichts.
Zack, Handy gefried.
Das Handy lädt schlicht und ergreifend nicht. Ach so, ich soll es vielleicht erst mal einschalten.
Oh, das Ding ist gerade ausgegangen. Der Bildschirm hat sich angeschossen und wieder an direkt.
Ich habe gerade echt gedacht, es ist wirklich Monika Smoke.
In dem Moment hat sich quasi der Bildschirm deaktiviert und dann ist es wieder angegangen.
Okay, das Handy lädt. Funktioniert gut. Ah, wo ist mein USB-Strommesser?
Leute, ich habe übrigens etwas ultra-nices gefunden. Das probieren wir jetzt noch aus.
Ich habe euch doch gezeigt, ich habe mir so einen USB-Meter gekauft.
Und zwar habe ich nämlich gefunden auf GitHub, dass es ein Web-Interface für mein USB-Strommesser gibt.
Ich habe mir so ein Ding hier gekauft auf Amazon. Amazon.
Nee, nicht U3434U. Ach, irgendwie so hieß das doch.
Das da habe ich mir gekauft, UM34.
Da kann man sich angucken, wie hoch der Stromverbraucher ist von USB-Geräten und sowas in der Richtung.
Was, da gibt es einen Hut? Nee, kein Hut. Ach, du meinst nicht, für Dora die Diskussion.
Und das Problem ist, das geht nur mit China-App, wo wir wieder beim Thema China-App sind.
Und jetzt will ich mal gucken, wie viel mein Handy zieht aus der USB-Steckdose.
Und deswegen müssen wir das Ding mal unter Ledungs installieren, dass ich meinen USB-Meter unter Ledungs verwenden kann.
Oh, da probiere ich jetzt noch mal schnell aus.
Meine Steckdosenleiste funktioniert ja anscheinend.
Ist das gut oder Müll, könnte gebraucht und ich finde es ganz angenehm.
Also ich würde mich jetzt da nicht darauf verlassen, wenn es dir auf irgendwelche Milliampere Nachkommastellen ankommt.
Aber so für eine grobe Richtwerte ist das schon ganz okay.
Via Bluetooth? Nee, das war aber nicht.
Ah, ich habe also einen USB-Smartmeter von Ruideng.
Oder Ruideng.
Doch nie gehört.
Klingt aber irgendwie ziemlich chinesisch.
Es hat China-Crap eigentlich.
Simple Web GUI, Python 3.
Okay, wie kann man das installieren?
Leute, wir schließen jetzt unseren Raspberry an, weil ich habe Schiss, dass ich damit irgendwie was an meinem Desktop kaputt mache.
Wir schließen nochmal den Raspberry an und der ist glaube ich noch angeschlossen.
Wir machen das lieber auf dem Raspberry, ich traue der ganzen Sache nicht so genau.
Install Requirements.
Ach so.
Ja langsam weiß man schon, wie die Pakete heißen aus dem Kopf, Alter.
Ah, wenn man es dann auch richtig schreibt, dann funktioniert das auch.
Run, Python Web.
Das ist ja einfach.
Das ist ja easy as a fuck.
Einfach das Smartmeter anschließen.
USB-Meter mit Serial Interface für Smart Check.
Das ist halt Next Gen alles hier.
Ach so, wenn ich das jetzt an dem Raspberry anschließe, kann ich das am Raspberry und an der Steckdose gleichzeitig anschließen?
Oder nur an einer Sache?
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Werden wir gleich herausfinden, was passiert.
Ich stöpsel schon mal an den Raspberry dran.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was er macht.
Mehr als Monkey Smoke kann es ja nicht geben.
Ok, es ist dran.
Nee, mir kommt es nicht so sehr auf die Nachkommastellen an.
So eine Hausnummer reicht.
Find your Serial Port in Device Manager and fill Serial Port Input.
Oh, das installiert er immer noch.
Das wird aber ganz schön lang.
Na gut, der Raspberry ist halt einfach nicht so schnell.
Hast du schon mal Factorio gezockt?
Doch, habe ich schon.
Factorio ist ein richtig nicees Game.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt jetzt so ein ähnliches Spiel wie Factorio, aber in 3D.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Construct?
Irgendwas mit Construct kann das sein?
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Das sah eigentlich ganz cool aus.
Factorio ist ein sehr nicees Game.
Satisfactory?
Ja, das könnte es sein.
Ehex, haben wir das nicht sogar mal zusammengespielt, Factorio?
Nein, das war etwas anderes.
Das war jemand anderes.
Ich habe noch nicht Factorio.
Haben wir Multiplayer gespielt?
Das war echt ganz cool.
Ach, das habe ich mit dem Click gespielt damals.
Genau.
Jetzt kommt Overwatch Squad.
Ja, die Overwatch Kampagne mit der Rakete, da musst du ja eine Rakete bauen, ist ja eigentlich
nur so der Einstieg in ganz abgedrehte Sachen, die du machen kannst.
Und es gibt auch sau viele gute Mods für Factorio.
Man kann später sogar Panzer fahren und sowas.
Nicht Overwatch Kampagne, Factorio Kampagne.
Am Ende musst du eine Rakete bauen.
Nein, die Rakete ist das Ende von der Kampagne.
Aber im Prinzip ist die Kampagne quasi so richtig das Einstieg eigentlich erst in das
Game.
Weil danach hat man gecheckt, wie das funktioniert und dann kannst du entweder Multiplayer spielen
oder freies Game spielen und ganz abgedrehtes Zeug bauen.
Da kann das Ding sich mal langsam ein bisschen zackig installieren.
90% der Sky Mods sind gruselig, 90% der Sky Mods sind irgendwelche Porn Fantasien von Leuten.
Und jetzt sagt nicht, dass es nicht so ist Leute, guckt euch 90% der Sky Mods an.
Ich hab jetzt direkt mit freiem Game angefangen.
Ne ne, ich spiel ruhig freies Game.
Das Factorio macht freies Game eigentlich am meisten Bock.
Konsole, das ist Gnome Terminal.
Gnome Terminal mit einem T-Max drinnen und ZSH als Shell.
Na ja, eine durchschnittliche Nodes Modules macht auch 30G groß.
Ha, fast.
Kann zwar 2-0 dranhängen.
Aber bei mir ist das auch nicht die durchschnittliche Anzahl an Nodes Modules.
Was macht das denn so lang?
Ich penn ja fast ein bei.
Als Ernst, also ich bin gerade so voll, voll, nachdem wir jetzt fertig geflasht haben,
also 100% nicht fertig sind wir noch nicht, das hab ich jetzt so voll,
und ich auch mein iPhone nicht kaputt gemacht hab, so bin ich jetzt gerade,
so ist die ganze Anspannung weg, ich bin jetzt voll am Gehen, ja.
Deswegen könnte ich es jetzt mal hinmachen und fertig installieren.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Ok, schauen wir mal nebenbei, ich hab ja schon die...
Kann ich eigentlich auf die Steckdose per SSH?
Klingt jetzt auch wieder irgendwie ein bisschen flirter, aber...
Ah, ich kann doch bestimmt SSH kon- ach Quatsch, nee, kann ich nicht.
Das ist ja ein ESP 8266, da ist mit SSH nichts.
Irgendwie war ich gerade beim Raspberry.
Aber schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal was... oh.
Raspberry, das ist nicht gut.
Macht keinen Scheiß.
OKS.
Oh, jetzt, oh, ich hab ne Idee.
Wir machen jetzt richtig das richtige Big Brain Play.
Und zwar, wir stöpseln den Raspberry an den USB-Anschluss von der Steckdosenleiste,
um dann mit dem USB-Meter, was wir am Raspberry hängen haben,
zu überprüfen, wie viel das Ding an der Steckdosenleiste zieht.
Noch was, oder?
Ja, was ist, das ist richtig, wie smart ist das?
Oh, jetzt fertig installieren, OK.
Ähm, Def.
Jetzt kann ich mal kurz gucken, als was das jetzt erkannt wurde.
Dieses komische, komische China-USB-Stick.
Was wurde der denn erkannt?
Außer, dass andere Voltage erkannt wurde.
OK, Raspberry, du kommst an den ordentlichen Stromanschluss dran.
Ich hab's mir überlegt, muss ich nicht mehr so abquälen.
Mein Handy lädt übrigens nicht mehr.
Was ich recht bedenklich finde.
Mein Handy lädt irgendwie nicht an der China-Steckdose.
Wahrscheinlich weil Apple erkannt hat, dass ich kein original Apple-Ladekabel hab.
Das geht, das geht ja gar nicht.
Was da nicht alles passieren könnte.
OK, Moment, jetzt kommt der Raspberry an die Steckdosenleiste dran.
Oh, es bootet.
Das ist echt total beknacktes Täusch, was wir hier machen.
Aber es geht.
Das ist ja das Wichtige eigentlich.
Es muss gehen.
Es muss nicht Sinn ergeben, es muss gehen.
Was streamst du so?
Also gerade stream ich, wie ich meine China-Steckdosenleiste flasche.
Beziehungsweise geflasht habe.
Weil eigentlich hat das Flaschen ja funktioniert.
Wir sollen mal gucken, was die USB-Anschlüsse so hergeben.
Follow-Wert, ja finde ich auch.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen? So was hier.
Drei, das wollen wir machen.
Läuft das jetzt und zeigt einfach nichts an?
Ah ja, hier.
Der kriegt schon mal wieder einen.
OK, also der Raspberry war auf eins.
Ne, auf zwei.
Fuck, was war die IP vom Raspberry?
Ah, zwei.
Und jetzt Port 5555.
OK, das ist das Webinterface vom USB-Meter.
Serial-Port.
Wir müssen jetzt noch gucken, an welchem Port das dran ist.
Ich ziehe es noch mal kurz ab und mache es wieder dran.
Erkennt er hier irgendwas?
Seht ihr hier irgendwie ein neues Interface oder ein neues Device, was aufgeploppt ist? Also ich nicht.
OK, vielleicht muss man das USB-Meter per Mikro-USB dran machen. Ich muss mal kurz ein Kabel holen.
Hier ist eins.
Ist ein Gefudel wieder. OK, USB-Meter, Mikro-USB. Ich USB-C, Mikro-USB.
So, und wenn es der Raspberry jetzt nicht erkennt, dann haben wir EPEC.
Dann ist zu spät. Dann klappt das nicht.
Das erkennt nichts, oder?
Ne, das erkennt nichts.
Was benutzt du für Netzmark 24? Immer 24.
Ne, OK, dann funktioniert das anscheinend nicht, was ich mir so vorgestellt habe.
Es ist schlecht.
Er erkennt auch null.
OK Leute, ich glaube das funktioniert nicht.
Wobei, das ist eigentlich so ein Ding, ne?
UM34C
Das ist genau so ein Ding, was ich habe.
Das da. Das ist genau das Teil, was ich habe.
Guckt. Aber Moment, das eine heißt UM34C.
Ist das ein Unterschied?
Ne, das ist das gleiche.
Ja, OK Leute. Keine Ahnung, warum er das nicht erkennt.
Hier steht auch keine. Was?
On Linux RF kommen kann? Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Was ist das denn?
Hä?
Bluetooth?
Ach so.
Ich muss das gar nicht per USB verbinden. Ich verbinde mich mit Bluetooth mit diesem Scheiß Ding.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Und wie verwendet man das jetzt?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie der Scheiß funktioniert?
On Linux RF kommen can be used. Ja, super.
Da weiß man ja Bescheid.
UM4CD, Google ist dein Freund.
Ja.
RF kommen.
Wie geht das? Keine Ahnung.
Welchen Passwort Manager kannst du empfehlen? KeyPass. Finde ich immer noch am besten.
Test.
RF kommen.
So was müsste ich jetzt hier auch haben.
Keine Ahnung, wie der Scheiß funktioniert.
RF kommen bind.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, was ich da mache.
Okay, scheiß drauf Leute. Ich stöpfe jetzt einfach mal kurz mein Handy so an das USB Meter und gucke, was bei rauskommt.
Und schaue mal, ob der USB Anschluss auch dazu taugt, ein iPhone schnell zu laden, was ja der China Hersteller versprochen hat.
Ein Ampere.
Das lädt es zumindest nicht langsam dran.
So gut, dann machen wir den Raspberry wieder aus.
Okay Leute, eigentlich sind wir fertig. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was ihr wissen wollt?
Oder irgendwas, was diesem Stream angefallen ist, was ich übersehen habe? Oder irgendwas? Gibt es noch irgendwas Spannendes, was ihr wissen wollt?
Please oben.
Wo?
Ich sehe nichts.
Post es einfach nochmal.
Man kann immer noch nicht suppen.
Ich spiele jetzt ja erst, wenn du entweder iPhone oder Partner bist und Partner kann ich jetzt erst wieder an meinen Antrag stellen.
Entweder wenn ich mich mit Twitter und YouTube verbinde auf Twitch und sage, ich habe schon Audience auf anderer Plattform.
Oder wenn ich jetzt wieder mal regelmäßig streame, weil man muss erst, man muss glaube ich innerhalb von einer gewissen Zeit 15 mal gestreamt haben.
Dass man sich wieder, dass man wieder applyen kann für Partner.
So sieht es aus.
Was frisst die Leiste an Strom im Idol?
Das kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen, weil ich das das Gerät zum zum messen im komplett anderen Raum gerade habe.
Da ist mein 3D Drucker dran.
Wir reden über Partner, wenn schon Partner.
Affiliate ist so.
Irgendwie halbes nenne ich ganzes.
Affiliate kann sie kann jeder jederzeit gefühlt machen.
Also so wirklich wirklich gut funktioniert das ja mit dem Aufladen auch nicht.
Ich würde sogar mal so weit gehen und sagen, das Aufladen funktioniert überhaupt nicht, weil mein iPhone sagt zwar es lädt auf.
Allerdings mein USB Meter sagt mir das iPhone braucht gerade 0,05 Ampere und damit lädt das garantiert sein Akku nicht auf.
Unter Garantie nicht.
Vielleicht sind die USB Anschlüsse auch fake und funktionieren nicht richtig.
Willst du nochmal erklären, warum du eine Linux vor allem auf Windows laufen lässt, um Raspberry zu erreichen?
Weil so Sachen einfach von Linux aus viel einfacher sind.
Ich meine, du kannst prinzipiell fast alles, wenn ich eine Weile nachdenke.
Verhält mir bestimmt genug Dinge an, die du unter Windows nicht oder nur schwer machen kannst.
Aber prinzipiell kannst du unter Windows auch alles machen.
Aber ich finde es ist einfach unter Linux viel einfacher.
Das fängt schon mit einer ordentlichen Kommandozeile an und das geht weiter mit einem ordentlichen Terminal Programm.
Mit einer ordentlichen Umgebung, die auf Tastaturbedienung ausgelegt ist, wenn man sowas macht.
Also ich finde es halt einfach deutlich einfacher letztendlich.
Machen kannst du unter Windows den meisten Kram auch.
Den meisten Kram.
Ich finde es einfach nur angenehmer, aber das ist Geschmackssache letztendlich.
Ach so, wir können ja nochmal gucken.
Was kann man jetzt hier eigentlich an der Steckdosenleiste so alles einstellen?
Also einen ausschalten können wir, das haben wir ja schon gelernt.
Oh, jetzt habe ich USB eingeschaltet, ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet.
Okay, funktioniert.
Was kann man hier eigentlich noch alles?
Information, Hostname, Sonoff, bla bla bla.
Home, mein Access Point.
Ja, okay.
Things, bla bla, Macadres.
Also wirklich was interessantes gibt es jetzt da nicht zu sehen, oder?
Das einzige Interessante an dem Ding ist die Mac-Adresse von dem Teil.
Dass man es vielleicht irgendwo freischalten kann, wenn man will.
Falls man das benutzt.
Was soll die Steckdose noch tun können?
Ja, theoretisch könnten wir da jede Menge machen.
Mit Tasmota kannst du ja glaube ich einige zusätzliche Sachen noch installieren.
Max benutzt so zufällig LED-Strips und irgendeinen LED-WLAN-Controller.
Wollte mir jetzt demnächst mal einen LED-WLAN-Controller...
Ne, aber ich habe vor für Weihnachten was zu bauen.
Ich habe mir auch schon die Kette gekauft.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich entweder mit genau dem gleichen Controller machen,
der hier in der Steckdosenleiste drin ist und am ESP866.
Wenn das geht.
Ansonsten habe ich einen ESP32.
Weil die letzten zwei Streams, die ich gemacht habe, ging es ja auch ums ESP32 programmieren.
Man kann es mit MQTT verbinden, ja.
Das werde ich auch machen für meine Heimautomatisierung, dass ich von da ein- und ausschalten kann.
Konsole.
Okay, ich weiß nicht was es macht.
Ich gebe da mal lieber nichts ein.
Wir können die Steckdose-Firmware upgraden.
Was natürlich echt witzig ist, irgendwo, ne?
Ich finde es witzig, dass man die Steckdose-Firmware upgraden kann, die Steckdose-Rebooten kann und sowas.
Configuration.
Was kann man machen?
Was kann man hier schönes machen?
Backup, Restore, Reset.
Module konfigurieren, das haben wir gerade schon gemacht.
WLAN haben wir auch gemacht.
MQTT konfigurieren werde ich noch machen.
Timer.
Ah, da kannst du...
Das ist doch zum Beispiel schon mal eine Funktion für Leute, die jetzt nicht so übertrieben
Heimautomatisierungszeug schon am Start haben.
Die können jetzt damit, Timer geregelt, irgendwelche Sachen ausschalten.
Ich mein, ich würde sie wieder über Home Assistant, über meine Heimautomatisierung machen.
Aber letztendlich, wenn man einfach nur seine Steckdosenleiste geflasht hat, dann...
...kommt man schlecht.
Ja, wer weiß auf welcher Zeitzone das eingestellt ist.
Stimmt, wie kann man eine Zeit einstellen?
Okay, aber Timer, das ist schon mal eine Funktion, da hat man direkt was von.
Dass man das geflasht hat.
Configure Logging.
Kann man sonst noch konfigurieren, MQTT in Generic.
Machen wir alles net.
Template.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was es macht, ich lasse da mal die Finger von.
Ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was man damit noch einstellen kann.
Ach nee, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Also ich finde es cool.
Ich finde es echt sehr nice.
Vor allem, auch wenn ich jetzt eine Weile hier rumgemacht habe, weil wieder gesidetrackt wurde ohne Ende.
Muss man noch sagen, an sich war das Flaschen wirklich...
Nee, falscher Knopf, das Flaschen war doch wirklich...
Oder?
Das war doch wirklich easy as a fuck, das Flaschen.
Auf den Raspberry den Git Repo auschecken.
Paar Pakete installieren, Skript starten und die Anleitungen durcharbeiten.
Das war wirklich einfach.
Ich habe mich mit das Mutter nicht weiter beschäftigt, was es noch kann.
Vielleicht kann sie damit ja wirklich LEDs ansteuern und ich könnte meinen Power-Button blau gestreift leuchten lassen anstatt zu kröten.
Kannst du noch mal Refling posten?
Den habe ich nicht mehr, aber der Sebaro hat den glaube ich noch.
Ah nice, nice, ja.
Logonautics, ja das glaube ich auch.
Deswegen ist es immer gut, wenn man so etwas direkt, wenn man einfach erst mal eine gewisse Weile googelt, wenn man ein Problem hat, weil oftmals findet man die Lösung.
Und dann deutlich schneller als wenn man sie selbst ausgedacht hätte.
Dimmer...
Light.
Könnte ich jetzt, könnte ich jetzt das hier irgendwie die LED konfigurieren?
Ah, nee, nee, nee, nee, nur, nee, nur wenn ich hier die passende LED dran habe, habe ich aber nicht.
Okay, nee, nee, dann geht das nicht.
Gut, aber ganz ehrlich, ich brauche meine Steckdose, auch keine customizable LEDs.
Hält sich doch in Grenzen.
Wie gefällt dir der neue Roborock nach jetzt knapp einem Monat?
Er ist komplizierter als der Eufy, dafür ist er im Prinzip besser mit dem Laserscanner und der ist auch schneller und saugt besser und kann theoretisch auch nass putzen.
Er ist ein bisschen höher als der Eufy, das heißt ich verwende beides noch.
Und was an dem Roborock wirklich nervig ist, da sind sie aber gerade bei der Firma dran, da zu basteln und zu entwickeln,
dass wenn du den vom Erdgeschoss im ersten Stock trägst, vergisst er die Map.
Die musst du dann erst wieder restoren lassen.
Das Handling von dem China Roboter ist nicht so schön einfach wie beim Eufy.
Wobei der Eufy ist auch ein China Roboter und der ist halt dumm, der kann nichts.
Der hat keinerlei Smartfunktion, der fährt einfach geradeaus, Wand, Bam, Kurve, Wand, Bam, Kurve, Wand, Bam und macht so den ganzen Raum.
Da ist der Roborock schon besser.
Ja, Leute, ich hoffe euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Mal gucken, was wir als nächstes machen.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Ideen habt, könnt ihr die mir gerne auf Twitter schreiben.
Wieso streamst du eigentlich 48 FPS, weil mir FPS besser sind.
Ach so, 49. Ja, das nächste Mal stream ich mit 49.
Wenn euch was einfällt, könnt ihr mir das gerne auf Twitter schreiben.
Oder hier irgendwie als Command geht, glaube ich, auch irgendwie auf Twitch.
Aber auf Twitter sehe ich es auf jeden Fall.
Hast du schon mit Valle Tudo geflasht?
Jaja, habe ich drauf auf meinem Roborock.
Ja, es klappt. Guck, MrBeatBrot hier.
Klappt alles.
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Ich habe jetzt noch eine zweite Steckdosenleiste, die geflasht werden muss, aber das mache ich alleine.
Weil so spannend war jetzt der eigentliche Flashvorgang ja auch nicht.
Ich habe mir so eine LED-Kette für Weihnachten geholt.
Habe ich aber noch nicht null mitgemacht.
Wie ist das so? Wollt ihr auch mal flashen?
Naja, besser auf jeden Fall als die China-Firmware.
Die China-Firmware braucht ja auch die China-App dafür, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, Sebaro schreibe ich dir dann nachher was zu.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal aufs Klo.
Ich mache den Stream aus.
Leute, macht es gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
C.O.